e
ni
good afternoon everyone we're going to
begin this work session of division
three house finance committee and we'll
open that work session at this
point for the record I am state
representative Moren money of the town
of miramac I'm the vice chair of
division 3 our chairman representative
Jess Edwards is unable to be here
today A couple of things uh in advance
of our presentation
today first of all the
Medicaid work session part two has been
scheduled as you recall we met last
Friday on that and uh there was a
request multiple requests to have an
additional session on that so that's
been scheduled for March 5th at 9:00
a.m.
the deadline our deadline uh to make
recommendations and to move forward on
amendments possible amendments to the
budget to the full finance committee is
the end of March so March uh 26
27th I just want to remind everybody
that the documents we work from uh the
presentations that we receive and other
various handouts that we work off of
that are working documents are all
online in two locations so the LBA page
which is off of the general court page
and then also the department of
administrative services keeps track of
all of
that I won't be taking any motions today
no roll calls or anything along that
line no votes
today tomorrow morning some weather uh
surprisingly enough it's not my
intention to cancel however if things
change between now and then I'll
certainly send out a notification by
email to all of you and I would direct
your attention to the general court
website where a banner of uh notice of
cancellations or delays due to inclement
weather appears at the
top all right just to review a little
bit with members of division 3 and the
public when we will meet I just want to
go through this so so we meet tomorrow
at 10:00
a.m. that's February
27th we meet on March
3rd at 10:00
a.m. we meet on March
4th at 10:00
a.m. we'll meet on March 5th at 9
a.m. we'll meet on March 10th at 10:00
a.m.
March
11 at 10:00
a.m. March
12th at 10:00
a.m. okay if our presenters could Madam
chairman yes representative tarki thanks
quick question I know um representative
Stringham had replied to an email Thread
about scheduling yes about afternoon so
for example that 9: a I believe it was
the March 5th 9:00 a.m. that was
scheduled um it didn't say an end time
or if we were going to move into the
afternoon do you know on those morning
starts should we assume we will be
working after lunch also for scheduling
purposes yes excellent question and I'm
in the same situation as you I don't
know the exact time frame I would plan
for after lunch but I don't I think it
will be an all day session but perhaps
um Mr White could give some clarity to
that as we go along with regard to the
Medicaid part
two section if you have anything to
contribute to timing on that sure um C
currently we had scheduled uh tely As I
understood it scheduled that until
approximately 12:00 p.m. um for that
presentation and one point of clarity
the um March 12th I I currently have the
prescription drug affordability board
scheduled for 1 p.m. in my calendar is
that
assistant um so I think we sorry if I
could interrupt absolutely we ended up
needing to schedule that for 10: a.m.
because there may be a full committee
public hearing that afternoon but that
has not yet been
scheduled that was my understanding as
well in the notice I received um it was
Wednesday the 12th at 10:
a.m and that is the prescription drug
affordability board that's the notice we
all received so uh we'll try to work on
timing yes representative nil vanco on
the weather what how early do they post
that do you you know because some of us
leave early to get here right you have
any idea when they you know how early
they post that uh I would think we'll
shoot for uh 8 AM you would get an email
by that time yeah frame okay thank
you all right
okay our presentation today as was duly
noted and published in our calendar and
outside of the room for today Wednesday
February 26th at 1M is a budget work
session on the division for children
youth and families we've all been given
uh the handout which should be online or
will be shortly I notice you know
speaking of timing representative tersi
that this presentation is a 33 page long
uh sort of as a scale the one on Friday
was 70 pages long and that took us about
4 and 1 half hours to get through uh so
my thought is this may be an indication
as for timing but uh we will see it's my
intention today to let everybody speak
who wishes to speak and any members of
the public who wishes to speak after the
formal in presentation is certainly
welcome to do so so I would just ask
that our presenters make very clear who
they are and where in the budget what
page and account unit we're working from
that would be very helpful before we
begin any comments at all from members
of division
3 we are ready to start Mr White when
you're ready thank
you good afternoon my name is Marie
Nunan I'm the director for the New
Hampshire division for children youth
and
families good afternoon Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer Department of
Health and Human Services and I'd like
to direct the committee to the
governor's operating budget um it's page
47 and it's beginning the DCF budget
begins with accounting unit
1896 and then we have also handed out um
the DCF um budget briefing book section
and just as a reminder and that begins
on page one it's exclusive to DCF and
just as a reminder the only accounting
units that are included in the budget
briefing book are those in excess of a
million doll State fiscal year so there
will be some accounting units that fall
under that threshold that you won't
necessarily see within the budget
briefing book and with that said I will
turn the presentation over to Marie
great thank you so I'm going to begin on
page two on slide two of the
presentation and you can see there the
dcyf mission which is to partner with
families and communities to provide
resources and supports that lead to the
safety and healthy development of
children youth and the communities in
which they live
moving on to slide three this is an
overview of dcf's primary
mandates you'll see the first mandate is
child protective services which is RSA
169c and through our child protective
services we investigate and assess
allegations of child abuse and neglect
and provide for the safety permanency
and well-being of children who are
victims of abuse and or neglect or
children at risk of maltreatment
DCS DCF also oversees Juvenile Justice
Services which are to rsas 169b for
delinquent and RSC RSA 169 D for chins
or children in need of
services and through our JJs Services we
support Children and Youth to remediate
challenges with delinquency to promote
child family and Community safety and
support Children and Youth identified as
children in need of services
DCF also oversees the senuna you
Services Center through RSA
621 and through this work we provide a
safe and secure environment for detained
and committed youth who receive Crisis
Intervention Mental Health Services
treatment services in a secure
setting we ensure the safety and
well-being of committed and detained
Youth and overall safety of the
community
slide four provides an overview of dcf's
bureaus and program
areas in addition to the director and
deputy director there are seven Bureau
Chiefs Who oversee a discrete set of
responsibilities and this team Works
collaboratively across the table to meet
our agency
responsibilities page five walks through
some of our key accomplishments and
highlights you'll see in the top
rectangle regarding dcyf
Workforce uh vacancies and assessment
case workers and those are our case
workers that uh complete investigations
of abuse and neglect uh we've seen a
decrease from 9% to 4% when we compare
December of 2023 to December of 2024 so
in the past
year similarly vacancies in our Juvenile
Justice officers has decreased from 4%
to zero when we compare December of 2023
to December of
2024 vacancies in our youth counselor
positions which are the positions that
are um youth facing at Our senuna Youth
Services Center have decreased from
56% in December of
2022 to 21% in December of
2023 and to 133% in December of 2024 so
we've seen significant decreases in the
vacancy rate of of our youth counselors
Miss Nunan would you um Mind questions
in between your presentation be happy to
okay representative tarki for question
thank you very quickly I'm just I'm
pleased to see that the vacancy rate has
dropped significantly can you give us
your um view on what was the most
important factor
there um fortunately there has been um
some raises built in from the
legislature which has been um supportive
um of our of our staff and our client
facing positions um so that's been a
positive movement um additionally we
made some changes to the way that our
child protection positions and our youth
counselor positions are posted working
with the state to post them in what we
call a mass recruitment fashion so it
eliminates the need for a potential
applicant to apply for uh various
position numbers for the same position
and allows um a ghost position number a
phantom number to be posted uh online
and for hiring managers to be able to
peruse the array of available position
numbers and higher into what's available
rather than asking applicants to
repeatedly apply uh by position number
which was a strain for applicants so
those are a couple of areas additionally
at at
syc um we have uh fine-tuned our
programming uh we're putting forth a
trauma informed model uh we have um some
new Administration we have a a fairly
new director um a new deputy director
position um some positions really
aligned toward making sure that we've
got programming there clinical supports
in place we've got additional clinical
staff so the programming and stability
at syc has really allowed uh for the
youth counselor position to be more
stable uh and to minimize um uh or
maximize retention you're
welcome and and in in addition to that
just just providing um more of a
budgetary perspective on that um for the
bium in June 30th
2023 um we did have a Personnel back of
the budget cut uh in excess of $22
million and prior to that um we also the
state was under a hiring freeze during
the initial phases of the pandemic um in
the current bium the back of the budget
cut was more Broad in the sense that we
could satisfy that reduction through um
through any other class line uh that
didn't have a restriction on it um so
that that globally as a department that
opened up our ability um to hire for
those positions because we weren't uh in
in in addition to the many strategies
that Marie described we weren't unfund
specific positions and had no
opportunity to hire for
them representative Neno for a question
yeah very very quick question these are
all full-time positions that that we're
talking about here that's correct and uh
any part-time position positions or
anything that's contracted out we do
have some part-time positions um at syc
for the youth counselor position um
those are harder to um recruit for we've
had some interest and wanted to have
them available so that we had the the
the best array of uh of candidates and
positions and options available but it
is a bit harder to recruit for the
part-time positions okay thank you
you're
welcome moving down to the second a
rectangle serving Children and Families
earlier so this is really a Hallmark of
the work that dcyf is is is working
toward is moving toward as I talk about
our agency priorities over the next two
years we're really shining a light on
serving families at their earliest time
of need and a couple of highlights in
this area to date uh in the first bullet
is our community Navigator program at
our Central intake which is our hotline
so if a reporter um someone with a
concern for a child calls our Central
intake there's a community Navigator
available so that if the call of concern
will not result in an open investigation
with DCF there is somebody that can
reach out to the family or to the
reporter to provide resources so this is
an early effort to connect families that
may have needs uh but for which any
concern for abuse neglect has not come
to that full that full level they can
still receive some resources information
to be able to meet their family needs
before needing to come to DC's attention
so we've seen some increase in referrals
um and we've had 807 referrals um since
August of 2023 so that's a significant
amount of families receiving um a touch
Point uh outside of the DCF
system in the second bullet community-
based voluntary services this is also a
service uh with case management that
happens outside of DCF um
with community-based voluntary Services
these families have had an investigation
for child abuse or neglect at the
conclusion or throughout the
investigation we conduct a risk
assessment and for families that come in
at moderate high or very high need we
can offer them a community- based
voluntary service where we have a couple
of community providers who um depending
on the area of the state the family is
from will will um provide case
management can provide for services can
ensure that they are going out meeting
with families again trying to eliminate
the potential of another call to dcyf
Central intake when there's been no
abuse or neglect
determined the third bullet down is our
Juvenile Justice
transformation um through our Juvenile
Justice transformation uh We've
developed an assessment process where
law enforcement prior to filing a
delinquency petition regarding a youth
will first call our Central intake our
hotline and request uh Juvenile Justice
assessment and we have some juvenile
probation and parole officers whose
responsibility it is to meet with youth
and families assess whether the youth's
needs can be met in the community um and
thus diverting them from the juvenile
justice system from coming into this
deep end of the system through diversion
programs other Community Resources so
our Juvenile Justice transformation
effort has been very successful um we're
we've seen a 30% reduction in juvenile
probations from calendar year 2019 to
calendar year
2023 moving to the third rectangle
representative Daniels for a question
sure thank you if you go on
um on on the uh
intake if someone was
suspected that there may be child abuse
or that that there might be in the
future is that something that they would
call intake on and let me give you a
specific thing sure my school board
recently passed a policy that says that
a teacher could withhold information
from a parent if they suspected that
sharing that information with the parent
might
cause abuse of the child is that
something that would be handled and how
how does the department handle that or
do don't they get involved in it if
anyone in in the state of New Hampshire
everyone is a mandated reporter and
every citizen so if anyone suspects that
their a child is being abused neglected
they're mandated to call dcyf Central
intake our hotline will process those
reports um if there's a belief that by
informing um a parent or caregiver that
the child could be in danger that could
be a reason not to first talk with the
parents but in the majority of cases we
are hopeful that um educators are
working with families talking with
parents about observations they're
making uh regarding their children
because there could be opportunities to
help support families before abuse
neglect happens so we certainly
encourage that collaboration between
Educators and the children that they
serve do th do those get reported to the
uh to the department if if it's
suspected for you know if if Mrs Smith a
teacher thinks that uh she doesn't want
to share information because she
suspects that it might happen is that
something that would be reported to the
department yes if they if they are
concerned that there's abuse neglect
happening could be happening any Su any
suspicion whatsoever they should be
calling Central and okay because and I'm
just trying to separate that sure uh
from the second part that that it has
happened versus I think it might sure um
it would it would be it would be
challenging for a teacher to be able to
assert whether or not abuse or neglect
has happened in every instance so any
suspicion should be called in so that
DCF can assess that and make that
determination yeah I'm I'm more
concerned about the I think it might
happen not that it has
happened okay thank you yeah you're
welcome representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman um
back to your Juvenile Justice
transformation and assessment do you
have any numbers for um calendar year
2024 I do
if you turn to slide
17 on slide 17 um there's uh Juvenile
Justice data um the pink line in
particular shows the Juvenile Justice
assessment the count of Youth um is is
on the left axis so the count of Youth
serve through the juvenile uh justice
assessment um is included on this on
this uh depiction
so are we continuing to see a reduction
so what we're seeing on this slide on on
again on slide 17 um the Gold Line the
yellowish line is the count of Youth
served in home in Juvenile Justice right
the blue line is residential so what
what I'm seeing here what we're seeing
at dcyf is a reduction steady slow but
steady reduction in our inhome Juvenile
Justice cases while the residential
treatment has declined a bit it's
staying fairly fairly steady so what
this says to me is that those youth that
can be diverted through the and have a
JJ assessment are most likely the youth
that could have been served in home but
were able to decrease even the inhome
served families and that certainly saves
time for court law enforcement Personnel
Juvenile Justice System overall so we
are seeing an impact in the data great
thank you thank you
uh moving to the third rectangle on uh
Slide Five kinship
care um kinship care is something we're
really proud of I do have a data slide
um in in the subsequent Pages as well
but what we're seeing currently is that
the initial outof home placement with is
with kin is happening 74% of the time
and that's up 45% um in this state
fiscal year so what this means is that
when a child um needs to come into out
of home care because it's no longer safe
in their in their family of origin we
first want to place in kinship care
which means it's someone known to the
child it's a relative it's a coach it's
someone that has a relationship with a
child you may be familiar the
legislature supported us in passing new
kinship law so that's been very
successful for us and for families um so
we're seeing kinship care currently
surpassing kids in out of home foster
care uh which is which is which is a win
a win for kids a win for families um so
that's a a really important um
accomplishment the second bullet in
kinship is that children served in
kinship care um again surpass those
served in foster care and what we're
seeing in the early data is that
children placed in kinship care seem to
be more likely to reunify with their
birth families so that's important
that's that relationship between the
kinship in the in the home of origin
that the parents um working
collaboratively and reunification is
looking like it happens more frequently
uh more often when children are first in
kinship care representative walner for a
question
you what kind of resources are Kip um
placements provided I mean do they
receive a foster placement um payment
just like a foster family would what
kinds of things do we do for them yep
yep so we are processing um a rule and
an ability to
um be able to pay Foster um kinship
families the same stien as a foster care
parent uh once they're licensed so that
that's equal uh we also can provide the
same kinds of services so if the child
and family could benefit from an inhome
service to support any challenging
symptoms that the child is exhibiting
any needs that the caregivers have to
provide for the for the child in their
home those same array of inhome services
are available as as they are for foster
families can I have a
followup I think I heard you say that um
when they are eligible to be licensed so
the kinship um family goes through
licensing just like a foster family yes
there's some slight differences in the
licensing but there's a a license um and
that was legislatively put through um
recently and so it does allow those
families to have a license it's a it's a
bit of a different license than the
Foster families um but then allows for
that stiped as well great thank you
thank you representative n vano followed
by representative priest thank you madam
chair a a quick question not not a lot
of detail but the front-end process of
what's the time frame involved for
identifying kinship uh uh Alternatives
and then the licensing process what what
is the timeline on that look like um
things move very quickly at DCF um so
when we determine um that a child is in
danger and needs to be removed from
their home uh we're immediately talking
with caregivers with the child trying to
identify important people in a child's
life um it's certainly our preference to
place with kin um over foster care so
we're working immediately um even before
oftentimes um danger is identified to
try to talk with families about if your
child couldn't be with you who are the
important people in in your child's life
um so we do some of that proactive
planning in our investigative process
and then the timeline for licensing um
it can be very quickly we have um the
ability to um do some initial steps
around safety some background checks
some police checks some things that will
happen very quickly so that in a matter
of days we could be providing payment to
that Foster Family while they continue
to go through the rest of the
process okay and a very quick follow up
on I think uh uh representative walner
uh question so the the difference is it
exactly the same funding for for kinship
as it is for It Foster
yes thank
you representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman um
with all of these key
accomplishments uh do you have or has it
been done any dollar assessment of the
money that has been saved to the agency
because of these new
programs like for instance transitioning
the uh children to Kin Care versus
foster
care so in in that example we're still
paying families to be able to provide
for that care the same amount yes okay
yes um you know I I think what we're
what we're hoping to see over time is a
transition uh you know as I go through
our resident as I go through our
strategic priorities you'll see a focus
on trying to reduce Reliance on
residential treatment so we believe once
we can do some of that that we will see
that we can transition funds um into
more community- Based Services What's
hard to predict is the intensity of
children's needs so we know that coming
you know in a postco world that we're
seeing youth with higher uh mental
health needs um and and just greater
Acuity and so we've not reached that
reached that Tipping Point yet where
we're a ble to see that reduction in
residential treatment but we do believe
over time
um that it's possible that we can
repurpose those funds into Community
Based
care um the final rectangular box on
Slide Five is just additional support
for transition aged Youth and so we have
our hope program which stands for
housing and opportunities to personally
Excel and through this service we're
seeing that voluntary foster care to 21
um is available uh for kids who were in
our state custody at age 18 and who
volunteer to extend care um we've
provided that to 13 we have a service
called Youth Villages life set which is
life skills Education and Training and
we provided that opportunity to 205
youth in state fiscal year 2024 which
was up uh from State fiscal year
2023 and then we've continued our
Partnerships with housing authorities
for fostering youth Independence housing
vouchers um and through this effort we
uh partner with local and state um
agencies and we connect young adults
underage 24 to vouchers so that they can
obtain housing
vouchers representative n van go for a
question yes yes thank you madam chair
so what are the overall uh demographic
of the populations you serve look like
how does you know if you if you have any
information on that so we serve children
um we can serve children through um our
child protection Juvenile Justice
typically 0 through 18 and there are
opportunities to extend um as as I just
shared for that um hope program we have
extended foster care so for youth who
would like some additional assistance
launching into adulthood who were
involved in our system at age 18 we can
continue to do that up to age 23 we have
some Services um and Community Resources
available through age 26 so we certainly
want to stick by youth to make sure that
we can launch them into adulthood um
into independent adults um and certainly
we serve um families uh adults all
across the state who are parents to
their children just just a quick
followup and I was talking about I I
think more trying to get a feel for so
the split between the youth that you're
you're Serv serving so in those various
categories it concentrated on the front
end concentrated on the higher end of
the scale and then more importantly uh
the split between male female uh in in
the
demographics I don't have the
demographics with me today regarding
male and female uh youth um that your
sense of things that that um uh it's
skewed one way or the other no I I don't
think I could answer that I I think
perhaps our Juvenile Justice population
um and and at our secure treatment
facility is um probably 2third male uh
oneir female um but for a child
protection I would say it's probably
close to
5050 okay thank you very much you're
welcome moving on to slide six uh this
is where I have outlined our DF
strategic priorities and it's really
important that I let you know the work
that we're doing looking into the future
the improvements that we want to see in
our DCF system so within the center of
the slide you'll see a circle and in the
in that Circle and it's color
coordinated but those are our four
strategic priorities for 2025 and 2026
and they're focused on our case practice
building our new secure treatment
facility developing our new electronic
case management system and focused on
ensuring we have a robust service
array in particular I I also want to
talk about the the the squares on the
outside of the circle so following the
practice the the navy color so we have
some strategies in place activities in
place to focus on fine-tuning our case
practice and through those efforts We
Believe will reduce the percentage of
Youth and residential treatment and then
subsequently will increase the
percentage of foster youth who live in
family settings kinship relative and
Foster family
homes following around the circle to the
right our new secure treatment facility
will be open by December of
2026 all employees will be trained in
our trauma informed care and the census
will not exceed 12 youth at any point in
time moving down to our electronic case
management system this new system it
will be called Granite families we do
have a question Sor no problem is this
flow okay for you absolutely pleas stop
me representative tarki for a question
yes just a quick question on that
statement that the census will never
exceed 12 youth is how can you guarantee
that or what's your plan to make sure
that sure that's the case there's a lot
of work to be done to ensure that uh we
know our legislative mandate is not to
exceed 12 um our Juvenile Justice
transformation effort has gone a long
way to to show us that there is a
currently a reduction in use of um syc
and we have a group that's come together
um involving a variety of Community
Resources um law enforcement courts um
folks from DCF from children's
Behavioral Health uh from the Pearle
board um we have prosecutors we have
defense Council present so we know that
this is going to take a community effort
to figure out what else is available for
youth in particular detained youth um
and even a subset of detained youth are
this the subset of Youth um who are
detained after hours during the night
what else can we create that's available
for cool off periods um it could be that
something happened in the family home
but perhaps with a little planning with
the right service with the right kind of
foster home we could eliminate the need
for after hours um youth being detained
at syc so we have some areas of focus
but it will certainly take a
collaborative
effort um in the purple our electronic
case management system will be called
Granite families and we intend to have
that live by December of 26th it will
replace our um
1997 uh case management system called
Bridges um which uh is certainly not an
up-to-date um technological um option
for us and so we anticipate lots of new
efficiencies and are excited to have a
new system that will help our case
workers have a place uh to document the
work they do with families in an
efficient way so that they can spend
more time with kids and fam
uh moving to the final area which is the
green section which is our service array
we hope to see an increase of children
served in their own homes um and
increase foster home availability for
children in particular we have a gold a
goal around um the 14 to 17 year old
population um which is that same
population that's uh mostly at syc that
same population that might be over
represented in residential treatment so
we want make sure that we have a a
robust array of um Foster family homes
and we're still focused on kinship care
but for that 14 to 17y Old
population Miss dunan are we how are we
doing in terms of foster families um are
we at 100% are we at 90% if you had to
guess in terms of availability of those
who are trained and ready to go as
Foster families where are
we so foster family availability is a is
a difficult question so uh we certainly
have um you know we've got almost 500
foster homes across the state who are
available um with more beds than than
that number of homes what's challenging
about foster care is that there has to
be a match between the skills and
capacity of the family and the unique
needs of the child so it isn't a one for
one so we can't take any child and out
of home care and say that's one child
there's one bed here let's make that
connection it has to be a family that's
comfortable that feels skilled that
feels confident and competent and their
capacity to serve whatever uh needs um
come with the youth so I don't know that
I would ever say we're at 100% capacity
of our foster care availability
certainly we we're recruiting we have a
fabulous um employee who is who is
fairly new to dcyf and is doing a great
job in recruitment uh we also want to
make sure we're doing a good job in
retaining Foster family and caregivers
by supporting them by giving them the
right Services by meeting with them
hearing them making sure they're a
partner at the table that's actually a
goal in our priorities um so do we have
availability yes is it always a Apples
to Apples fit for the needs of
particular Children and Youth no and so
we always are going to need to keep
recruiting we've got large sibling
groups some people want to take smaller
children we've got teenagers available
some people want a sibling group of two
we've got sibling groups of four right
so it has to be the right match so I
don't know that would ever be at 100%
capacity thank you for the detailed
question representative Nano yesk
detailed answer representative Neno very
quick uh question how often do you do
you find mismatches in in that uh
program where you match somebody with a
a foster I mean Foster or kinship either
either way what what kind of a mismatch
rate do you have and how how do you
address those I don't know that I have a
percentage for you but certainly we have
um kids disrupt uh from Foster family
and and kinship settings uh we try to
look at those and and make sure we think
of it um you know from a quality
assurance aspect in terms of did we
provide the right service are there
different services available that might
have maintained that child in youth what
are we learning about that youth
sometimes youth come into care and we
think we understand the youth's needs
and as kids get comfortable um either we
see symptoms exacerbate sometimes we see
them stabilize so it's always an
opportunity to better understand what a
child's needs is and also to provide
training to foster care parents so
disruptions certainly happen um and we
always hope that we learn from them and
and try to minimize that and know
exactly what the child would need the
next in the next home okay thank you
thank
you representative walner for a question
thank you I've been sort of looking
ahead to in the uh uh presentation to
see if there is any mention of adoption
and can you remind us of what the um
guidelines are around when a child ends
up in a situation where they're uh
they're terminate their family is
terminated sure yep so for each child
that comes into out of Home Care um we
have legislative requirements that we
have 12 months to work with the with the
family of origin to try to to rectify
and remediate the concerns that brought
the child to our attention so there are
um continual court hearing reviews uh
we're continuing to work a case plan
with the family we're meeting with the
child the family any service providers
um we're we're involved in treatment
meetings IEP and educational meetings so
our case managers our case workers are
constantly working with families over
the course of that 12 months um when a
child first comes into out of Home Care
reunification is the primary goal we're
also obligated to identify a concurrent
goal so sometimes that's adoption
depending on the the needs what we know
about the family how the the age of the
child what we um what we can anticipate
might happen um most often um adoption
is the concurrent goal because that's
the most um permanent other option
available after
reunification and so over the course of
that 12 months we're working both
primary and concurrent goals um with the
Court's oversight when we get to about
nine months into the into the course of
a case we'll start to really think about
is does it look like permanency is
imminent over the next three months
should we be doing more around the
concurrent goal and then at the 12-month
Mark there's a specific court hearing
called a permanency hearing and at that
time we're obligated to recommend to the
court that we um adopt an Alterna
alternative permanency goal and then
work toward that goal and at that point
it could be termination of parental
rights as recommended and then we would
be moving toward
adoption do you have a statistic of how
many children um in the past year have
gone into
adoption I don't have that on on the top
of my head I can get that for you um
certainly more children reunify than
than go to adoption but I can get that
for you great thank you thank you
moving to slide
seven this is a visual of what we
anticipate or where our goal will be as
a result of the priorities that I I
talked about in the prior slide and so
you'll see here that our our overarching
goal is to serve families with the
lightest touch possible and if we stop
at the bottom Circle which starts with
Central intake um I talked about that
Community Navigator program that's
available so we hope that we're able to
stop a family's um I don't know if I
should
pause that's okay I just wanted to pause
I wasn't sure um you'll see our if if a
family comes to our attention at Central
intake we hope that that's the only
involvement they have with our agency
we're giving out referrals we're giving
out information we can refer the
reporter or their family to the
community Navigator program so then
you'll see that stop sign we hope to
stop a family there if the information
requires us to do an investigation or an
assessment we can serve a family with
paid Services right through our
investigative process and we hope that
they family will stop there at the
conclusion of our assessment I talked
about those community- based voluntary
services with outside case managers if
that can be done again that could stop
the family from coming any more deeply
into our system than
necessary uh moving up to the third
circle if we do need to open a case if
we can substantiate and and need to
substantiate abuse and neglect we hope
to serve that family in home with that
lightest touch possible keeping the
family intact providing those community-
Based Services to keep them
together if we have to have out of Home
Care moving up to the second to the last
Circle we want to use kinship or foster
care options that communitybased care to
keep kids as close to home as possible
in community home settings um if that
can't be possible that Outer Circle
which is the deepest end of our system
is residential treatment and you'll see
those arrows um on the on the left those
Navy arrows if we're using residential
that should be a shortterm episode of
treatment we want to step kids back down
to kinship or foster care and then step
them back down to their own homes where
we can maintain that family intact so
this is just serves as a visual to
outline for you um our goal to serve
families with that lightest touch
possible question representative tersi
for a question so knowing that um the
time in residential care is the goal is
very very short what is your average
stay then for children I don't have that
today but I can certainly get that for
you um today I would say it would be
longer than we would want it to be and
so that that's why these are goals
making sure we're assessing engaging
families we're we're talking with them
at the table we're understanding
family's strengths and needs so that we
can build off those strengths work
through those needs um and get kids
moving through our system more quickly
but I can get that for you quick
followup would you say that it's days
weeks or
months I would say for the majority of
kids its months thank
you the thing I'll say about Residential
Treatment too is that we know that that
will always be a necessary part of our
service array Continuum those episodes
of treatment for those High Acuity youth
that I I talked about that we're seeing
in a postco world so we anticipate
there'll be a continued need for
residential treatment but we want it to
be treatment oriented as shortterm as
possible and that we're stepping kids
back through our system when we when we
can representative Stringham for a
question yeah so would would you say
then people enter resid final treatment
and then they graduate out of it back to
non-supported
nonobserved or once they're in it are
they kind of in it so that would be our
goal is to make sure that we're stepping
kids back through closing cases uh
reunifying families um there are some um
situations where youth have challenging
symptoms um we have some kids um who
have disabilities and will require
long-term care we often work across the
department with our long-term supports
and services
for some kids that might need adult care
so it there is a a varying I I think I
kind of asked it backwards I'm kind of
meant you know once you're in home
treatment and you're finished with that
then the case is closed and you're no
longer you don't pick up the phone
unless they call that's correct yep we
close out cases every day and uh connect
families with local Community Based
Services and hope that they live
successful independent lives outside of
DCF represent res ative seaworth for a
question thank you very much um given
that you have this goal represented with
the circles here to keep um family and
children in the center by what
methodology can you can you measure your
success towards that goal so we have um
a full metrics
um I don't think I can provide to you um
we have a full metrics outlining all of
our activities around our strategic
priorities with data points um for
example residential treatment we hope
that we'll see a reduction by 10% um
similarly we hope to see a 10% increase
um in the number of families served in
home uh we have percentages around um
numbers of foster home availability for
14 to 17 year olds so we have a whole
array of metrics that we'll use to
measure our success or our challenges
and we'll need to Pivot and and and
change up our strategy and figure out
how to meet
that representative Daniels for a
question thank you after after
assessment you you need to take further
uh treatment like in home or or foster
care how long are those records kept if
you're able to close a
case I'm G to I want to get back to I I
I think perhaps it could if we had a
finding and we opened a case I believe
the records are currently kept
indefinitely
and if it's unfounded if it's unfounded
is four years it's four years okay thank
you I'm going to correct myself um if
it's screened out it's retained for four
years um um and I think I will get back
to around if it's if it's if it's um if
it's unfounded let me get back to on
that so that I'm confident in the
response can you define what screened
outt means yes it means a call that
comes to our hotline um but is
determined did not meet criteria for an
investigation okay so you hold that for
four years that's correct but but if you
go through a case that's unfounded then
that's when you're going to get back to
me I'm going to get back to if it's
unfounded yes okay thank you
uh moving on to slide eight this is our
first Bureau that we'll review it's our
Bureau of field
services um and this is the Bureau that
most people uh think of when they think
of DCF it's it's our it's our case
workers it's our Central intake hotline
it's our child protective services and
it's our Juvenile Justice
Services on slide
nine you'll see that we're going to move
into the accounting unit
um and we're on page 847 of the
governor's budget at this point um and
accounting unit 1896 our dcyf emergency
funds um we use these for unexpected
costs for families things that are
outside of our service array um so it
could be things like um a car repair or
a bill that needs to be paid in order to
allow the family to stay intact so it's
not a service provider coming in but
it's an unexpected cost um that is
unable to be paid otherwise um in in
another part of the the community or the
system but enables a family to stay
together by being able to pay
that uh moving into accounting unit
2957 um this is our child protective
workers um so we've got almost 300 case
workers across the state um our Child
Protection staff are mobile they're
field-based um they're meeting with
families they're meeting with treatment
providers um education meetings Court
hearings so there's significant amounts
of travel uh we're available 247 on call
to respond to imminent danger of
children um so we've got our overtime
line there um you supporting supporting
Children and Youth uh 24 hours a day
seven days a week
it looks as though on page
849 where that accounting unit is
described that there is a reduction of
the number of
positions 30 or so that's fairly
substantial uh any expansion you want to
make on that sure uh 29 of those
positions were moved to accounting unit
3443 and two positions were moved to
accounting unit
2956 and and and we'll be we'll be going
through that where we can talk about the
the changes when we arrive at that
accounting unit if that works but um
those positions and the Personnel cost
were were moved uh through there so
there was no positions abolished uh
during this during this phase of the
budget representative walner for a
question get this closer here we go on
you skipped over page
848 the director's office and I see that
the personnel line is down
considerably and the um
positions are also
down so we will get to the office of the
director in another slide but we did
sorry that's okay we and and we did
again move positions to a different
accounting unit so there was no
reduction there okay there's no
reduction
just um I'm going to move to accounting
unit 2958 which is on page age 850 Madam
chair representative noveno for a
question thank you if I if I look on um
849 or line 102 where it has contracts
for program Services is that another
case of where the money's been shifted
someplace else yes those dollars have
also been moved to
3443 thank you
I'm moving to page 850 which is
accounting unit 2958 we're still on
slide
9 and and you'll see in this accounting
unit
um starting in class line 636 and moving
down this is um the majority of our uh
funding for our outof home care so our
foster care placement um Broken Out by
eligibility uh needs and requirements
for children how those are paid our
adoption subsidies for children who have
been adopted our Residential Treatment
dollars um so this in this accounting
unit is where you see um our placement
costs and of course as as I mentioned um
having foster care placement um is an
incredibly important service array uh
component that we that we have in our
robust array as is residential treatment
and while we hope to minimize that we we
know that there'll always be a need for
that that kind of uh level of care
representative walner for a
question well on 636 and
637 it seems like there is a Hu a pretty
big increase on line 637 from the last
bium and I
wondered
63 yeah so that's on page 850 of the
governor's budget yes
s um so there there's there's a couple
of things well can I just provide sort
of a broader uh context here so this is
certainly a unique uh accounting unit um
when comparing it to many of the
accounting units um we've we've
discussed and scen so far we break out
each type of service um here where we we
break it down by title 4E or title 4 a
tanif or state general funds so that we
can more accurately track the the types
of expenses um that are allowable and I
think what what is unique about also
unique about this is one of the things
that we're trying to do in the budget is
look at the costs we've incurred and
look at the cost that we're going to
incur but those costs are driven by the
unique needs of the child so if a child
qualifies for 4E or they qualify for
tanif um that or it's 100% General funds
we can't necessarily predict what the
future needs of those children are going
to be so one thing that you will see in
the regular Department wide transfer
three times a year we bring forward an
item to the fiscal committee where we
often move funds within this accounting
unit to adjust for those changes
throughout the year so we start with an
initial assumption based on experience
that we've seen in the past and then we
make adjustments so I I just kind of
want to put a little um just a little
sort of asterisk on on this conversation
but representative walner to answer your
question directly um we did have a
prioritized need that was funded in the
governor's phase relative to enhanced
foster care rates and I can go back and
verify but I believe we are seeing a
portion of that show up here and then we
also saw if you look at um State fiscal
year
26 we also found that the experience um
in state fiscal year 26 was almost
approximately what we had budgeted so I
think there's anticipation as Marie was
discussing earlier about us trying to
kind of move down that large Circle
toward towards the less restrictive
we're we're we're in hoping and
anticipating
higher utilization here ver versus
versus residential in the long
run I think you just answered my next
question but um does this budget include
any rate increases for foster
families sure so we submitted two
prioritized needs requests um one was an
enhanced foster care rate and that that
was in included and then we also
included a prioritize need request for
increased foster care rates more
standard rates um in the first year of
the banum the enhanced foster care rates
was uh almost $700,000 total uh and it
was the same in the second year the
increased foster care rates prioritized
need that was not funded was just shy of
a a million dollar in each state fiscal
year
representative priest for a question
followed by representative tarki thank
you madam chairman
um on page 850 toward the bottom um you
have estimated source of funds for Child
and Family Services uh I'm could you
give an explanation on the agency income
and why there is no agency income for
202 26 and
sure I I think I need to look further
into that and and get back to you uh
just to give you a floral response but I
I'll see if I can do that actively as
we're sitting here today uh as a
followup on the educational trust fund
I mean it was my understanding that
those monies those funds are supposed to
be used for
educational purposes and you have like
three million in each year um can you
explain
that
yes yes so there was a bill that was
passed during the state fiscal year 2024
legislative session uh Senate Bill
463 Senate Bill 463 made a $3 million
appropriation for State fiscal year 25
in the amount of $3 million directed
from the education trust fund um when
the agency prepared its budget we
continued this practice as it was
originally envisioned and passed by the
legislature um and I would defer to the
committee whether there's a policy
change in that
direction okay thank
you representative tki followed by
representative Nano before I get to my
first question do you know what the
policy was for cabel
oh actually I believe I misspoke I
believe it was HB 1588 H I can uh hang
on one second let me just verify
that so uh this one was to increase the
age from 21 to 22 uh for kids um in in
in DCF care um if they have special
education services yep thank you sorry
about that okay and then my original
question
um was somewhat unrelated but talking
about this population of children um
when it comes to their medical care do
they all get enrolled in Medicaid
regardless of what their family
situation is or how is that handled
sure so so typically
um
the most children typically qualify for
Medicaid that come in and um I I have an
individual here who's told me in the
past typically what they do is sign them
up initially because most of the time
they will be qualifying for Medicaid um
unless and and and then they go through
the process to verify that and then if
if they don't then they don't but but a
vast majority many of the children do
okay so you're using family income so is
there a chance that with our discussion
on Friday about premiums that you we may
have children affected as they enter
into your care with the increased
premiums or the establishment of
premiums for some
families I think I'd need to look into
the answer for that the the state is is
paying for for these children as they
come into our care so I think I need to
consult with a couple of different
people to understand what the
implications would be there okay but
just to clarify though when you talk
about if they're eligible you're using
the parents or the Guardians income to
see if they're eligible no I'm seeing
Trish CH say
no what what are you using
sure so so they would be an out of home
placement so the parents income wouldn't
apply at that
point okay thank
you representative walner actually I'm
sorry representative representative
novano followed by representative walner
thank you madam chair so a question on
it looks to me on the agency income that
there's a a pretty significant shift
between what part of it comes from
federal funds and what
uh uh portion is coming from the general
fund is there is there you know some
explanation for what's happening
there as as far as an increase in
general funds well so I'm looking at the
federal funds going from you know in uh
fiscal year 25 adjusted from 19 to
2022 uh on the federal and a general
fund from 4 3 to 53 so I'm looking at a
disproportionate uh shift in the
proportion of funding coming from the
federal versus the general state general
funds sure so
the the experience that we've had in
this panium was that we've had to move
almost $10 million of General funds into
this account and there there's a couple
of reasons for that but the experience
that we've had is that we have had um
fewer scenarios where we've been able to
leverage other Federal funding sources
and we've seen a a highing a higher
utilization of 100% General funds and
again that's based on the unique
circumstances of the child and so when
we prepared our agency budget what we
were trying to do is look at what the
experience has been look at how the
costs have been incurred and look at
what federal sources we've been able to
leverage and um For Better or For Worse
we've seen an increase in in general
fund utilization um and what we've tried
to do here is reflect
that so just a quick followup so um so
you're saying so for the previous B any
well from 23 22 23 uh the trend line
would look pretty dramatic in in that
respect it just looks like a pretty big
shift uh on the Assumption and you know
versus uh
sure so let me see here
um I I I can I can follow up with with
additional analyses and details to kind
of give a more thorough explanation on
that if if if that would work for the
committee yeah I I think that's right
because I'm interested to know whether
there's a you know something that has do
with the the federal funding changing or
uh what exactly accounts for the sure I
I I mean one of the things that that we
talked about last on on Friday evening
was where we have a loss of of uh
federal revenue because the residential
contracts are budgeted in three
different locations they're budgeted in
the 7948 account within Medicaid they're
budgeted within 2958 as well as another
account within the division for
Behavioral Health and we had talked
about the the loss of federal Medicaid
dollars um in in certain instances
relative to qualified residential
treatment facilities and institutions
for mental disease where essentially if
it's over 16 beds uh we are not able to
claim Medicaid dollars for certain
Services there and so because these
because these contracts um they they
collectively there's 15 of them they
exceed $100 million annually cuz they
cross the three different accounting
units I think it's difficult to look at
one accounting unit in isolation so I
think what may be best is if we work on
providing the committee an analysis that
shows the dollars across all three
accounts and how they tie out that that
will probably get to your to your
question a little more clearly than an
isolated conversation about one
accounting unit where a contract shares
three three
yeah just a quick very quick followup to
that we had uh I forget which
presentation it was we were talking
about doing a better job of making sure
that we were recovering everything that
was available to us on the from the
federal level and it sounds to me like
the fact that we're dealing with you
know three different U accounting units
on this U uh creates the opportunity for
not fully uh
recovering um the the the accounting
structure is is is fairly unrelated to
whether we claim the dollars or not that
happens at a much more detail level I
mean this is the state budget there's a
lot of things that happen behind the
scenes here so the be because our
contracts are are shared across multiple
division areas we try to account for
those dollars in multiple division areas
but I think it's but that makes your job
difficult when you're trying to
understand why this particular line is
changing when you don't have in in
Insider Vision into the other accting
units that are located 100 Pages away in
the budget okay thank you I look forward
to the some structure that makes that
easier to understand what's going on
there thank you representative walner
and then representative Stringham yes so
in the lines
um can you tell me what is included in
the lines of um on this page where are
the residential plac
basements the not kinship or not Foster
family but the residential are they in
here yeah so so uh
643 and um 644 are two locations but but
what I can do with that analysis is I
can show you each accounting unit in
each class line that are factored into
the residential
contracts um so that you can and you'll
be able to see that in a more detailed
manner if if that's
helpful just yes that would be helpful
and maybe a breakdown of how many
children are in those each of
those kinship foster and residential I
mean that probably is in your slide deck
someplace I'm sure I've already missed
it um I have one other question last
year I brought in a bill pertaining to
children who were in foster care who
have social
security and we were told that the
state takes of the um Social Security
payment when the child enters care where
would I find that
income in in the budget I I believe
that's the agency income but that's
where I want to go back and just verify
that okay and I see that you're
projecting none for this
coming vium that that's where I need to
go back and have a conversation
understand why that looks like that okay
one other about um House Bill
661 um there was a report that we're
going to hopefully see in this committee
uh and talk about but in the report they
refer to um the state of New Hampshire
being able to maybe claim more 4E
funds and I wonder if there's been any
um if the department has looked into
that and whether we're pursuing
that thank you yes uh we are um we are
pursuing that we have an active uh group
of departmental employees um it's a
complicated um if this then that if this
then that um sort of uh flow chart that
is required um with the qrps um that uh
Nathan described the qu um the
residential treatment programs uh with
the families first uh prevention and
services act uh in 2018 there the qrtp
was established the IMD Institute of
Mental diseases were established um
again where uh Nathan referenced um
homes that have more than 16 youth but
part of that also outlined a specific
flowchart of things that all needed to
be lined up in order to draw down the
for ref funding and I wish it were as
simple as if we just do this one thing
but right from contemplating residential
care and and children need a
comprehensive assessment of treatment
did it happen in this time frame in this
way what was the outcome of that you
know moving right into do we have the
right court order with the right date
within the right time frame do we have
the right documentation at the right
time so there's a complicated flow that
we are actively working through in order
to ensure that we can draw down those
funds great thank you representative
Stringham for a question yeah you had
mentioned the 10 million in general
funds was that the entire uh division 42
or was that uh just um uh this
particular department number sure so it
was just shy of 10 million for this
particular accounting unit we also had
to move about $3.5 million to the syc
budget um as well um is is there one
place where the entire um 42
division um uh sums and and breakout is
in the book I'm missing it
somehow yes on uh page
865 of the
budget thank
you moving to
moving to slide
10 um this is the part of the Bureau of
field services which is focused on
Juvenile Justice um rather than child
protection and I'm on page
861 accounting unit
7905 um so in this um accounting unit we
see the the field staff for Juvenile
Justice um and we see
um we see that we have 107 staff we
actually have zero vacancies oh I see a
question uh sorry representative uh uh
Neno um I'm trying to get my I'm trying
to get my head around the um increases
in the in the budget
so this is now in a you know covid
postco and I'm looking at the page where
we talked about all the accomplishments
and the progress we're making in the
various areas uh with the circles and
everything else else uh are and I think
when we looked at uh page 17 where we
showed the trend lines so it looks to me
like the trends are down to
stable uh and yet the some of the the
budget numbers are
increasing so it's just a you know some
explanation to help me get my head
around uh what's going on with the the
trends and the progress we're making on
on the key accomplishment areas and the
and the fact that the budgetary side of
it is um doesn't seem to totally reflect
that sure so I I think what's important
to start with is as I've already
mentioned um we've had to move quite a
bit of money into the budget and make
adjustments and um and when we talk
about the city use Services Center you
know the budget that we had to work with
was based off of a budget that was to
close um HB 49 of the 2023 legislative
session was an expedited bill that um
prevented the closure uh I believe it
was in March of 2023 and so when we
entered the house phase in the last
budget that that particular accounting
unit was based on a closed amount and
then we actually saw a million dollar
reduction during the house phase so it's
not necessarily an Apples to Apples
comparison when when you're when you're
looking at the at the current budgeted
amounts because it doesn't Express the
specific need and so what we've tried to
do um you know both with the the changes
in the qrtp IMD issue as well as what
we've seen and experience relative to
the needs with the Su new use Services
Center is make those adjustments we also
one important thing to understand about
the DCF budget it is heavily personnel
and there was uh you know the 10% and
then the subsequent 2% increase
in salary costs as a result of the raise
and then there's also been some
increases and I believe in the range of
seven or more percent each year relative
to benefits and so when you have a a
division area that is heavily Personnel
based or also going to see those adjust
those increases but what you don't see
in the current operating budget is those
pay raises were not included those pay
raises were included in hb2 so again
it's you just need to recognize the fact
that that if if you're looking at
chapter 106 laws of 2023 and the
operating budget there versus the
operating budget today it's not
necessarily easy to draw that comparison
so so there's a couple of different
drivers
there I I think that may be an
understatement that it's not easy to
draw comparisons but thank
you staying in uh Bureau Field Services
um accounting unit 7906 on page
862 um you'll see here
um that we are funding uh with mostly
federal funds um a number of contracts
um our Child and Adolescent needs and
strengths um assessment tool which
ensures that um is part of the
assessment process in our Juvenile
Justice transformation and ensures that
we're serving uh youth at the Right
Touch um in community based care uh or
service whenever possible um our
restorative practices around ensuring
that youth have some accountability to
their their victims um we have uh legal
consultation here for uh youth
contemplating the assessment outside of
the system so that if they want to be
able to consult with an attorney before
agreeing uh to that process they're able
to do so um so some of the uh funds in
7906 um cover those uh kinds of
contracts
uh beginning on slide 11 uh we have some
data uh to to demonstrate some of the
work in in in that field services Bureau
so on page 11 you're seeing the total
calls to our Central intake
line you're seeing there's a slight
decrease in total calls for State fiscal
year 2024 at the very top of that slide
um the bottom section shows the outcome
of the call by screen in and that's the
pink line and those that are are those
are uh calls that are investigated for
abuse neglect uh by our case workers um
those that are screened out which is the
blue line and so those are not sent for
investigation and additional information
uh which is the um yellow uh line and
the additional information are calls
received by Central intake that do not
meet criteria for abuse neglect um but
we are otherwise already involved with
the family so that um information is
passed on to the casew worker just as
supplemental information for their
awareness so in that reddish color with
the report screened in um you'll also
see that there's a decrease in screened
in calls by over a thousand and so sub
subsequently you'll see the number of
screened out calls then has also
increased and and this is a good Trend
this is positive we want less families
being called into DCF um and getting
into this deep end of the system uh we
want our system of care outside of our
system to be working for families to
have alternatives to meeting their
family needs um and not to have the only
path available um is is dcyf for them so
this is evidence of the legislature
support around the system of care um and
we're seeing we're seeing that that
happen representative Nell vano for a
question yeah again again here I'm
seeing you know the positive results of
you know your key accomplishments in in
terms of to some of these uh measures
and metrics but you know I'm having a
hard time relating it to what's
happening with the with the overall cost
structure but anyhow that you know we've
already covered that with some uh you
know request for some additional
additional information it will help us
sort out the the fruit salad and maybe
be able to picture apples oranges and
other things that are in
there moving to slide 12 um this shows a
trend over calendar years to 24 of
screened in reports so again those calls
that come to intake that do meet
criteria for investigation for abuse
neglect um and you'll see that um each
year follows a similar Trend um lowers
um of screened in reports are are fewer
in the summer months um you'll also note
the pink trend line for calendar year 24
shows a decrease in screened in reports
by month um over the past
years representative tki for question a
quick question looking on the seta would
you say that that's due to the child
being in school and schools being such a
vital part of protection of children
children most
definitely moving to slide
13 once a call is screened in it sent on
for our investigators our our case
workers um at the district office level
to investigate and so you're seeing here
the average assessments assigned per
cpsw from 2024 in December to December
of 2024
um it's a it's a fairly steady Trend a
few dips here and there but fairly
steady our our case load goal is 12
active investigations per case worker um
and that goal was established back in
2019 when we had received um a
additional uh case worker positions uh
We've not we've not quite reached that
goal but um but we've we've hovered
around 12 um on some
occasions slide 14 shows the open cases
so once our investigators have made the
determination um if we need to open a
case here is where we're looking at the
data of open cases um so the top of
slide 14 shows shows that number of open
cases for our family service case
workers um you see a very minimal
increase in open cases since 2021 by
less than 50 between State fiscal years
22 and
24 and so this reinforces something
we're seeing which is that the families
coming to our ention have greater needs
right cuz we so we're seeing um uh fewer
calls but we're not seeing necessarily
um a significant drop in cases so those
those calls coming to our attention um
are are families that have greater needs
um the bottom portion of this slide
shows the numbers of children served so
the pink being the total served when you
combine in home and in placement the
blue breaking it down by children in
placement and the gold being children in
home and the green prevention cases are
those uh children being served um
outside of DCF through our community-
based voluntary
services on slide
15 you're showing um you're seeing a
promising Trend in the past in the past
uh 90 days essentially since November of
2024 we've seen a 7% decrease in
children served in out of Home Care and
then inversely a 7% increase in children
served in their own homes so that's a
trend that we want to see um and would
be in the right
direction on slide 16 you're seeing our
family service case load so these are
our open
cases so this is the trend of the
average number of open cases per per
case worker from December of 2021 to
December of 2024 and the goal here is 10
Again established in 2019 with our
Senate Bill 6 case worker positions at
that time um we're seeing stability over
time and typically about 12 to 13 cases
per
worker representative tarki for a
question thank you I'm looking at how
this goes back to the end of 21 and
while it's relatively St
don't see really any reduction and over
the last few years I know that that was
hopefully a goal so what is still
holding you up in this well I think this
is this is um similar to what I
mentioned where we're seeing fewer calls
to intake um so what this says to me
though is the calls that are coming in
have greater needs um certainly we we
need legal criteria to open cases and
Court oversight and so um the the needs
of families is greater than it than it
was
thanks slide 17 we did uh take a look at
already that was our Juvenile Justice um
youth served um in home and through our
assessment and through Residential
Treatment slide 18 shows the average
number of cases assigned per juvenile
probation and parole
officer so the numbers stayed fairly
consistent despite that JJ assessment
process
um and and again I think it's it's
similar that and and we saw that on the
last slide where uh we're seeing that
dip in inhome cases for the assessment
process we also know that some of our
jpos are involved in in carrying those
assessment cases um and also carrying
permanency cases to ensure that uh our
Juvenile Justice youth are um getting to
permanency as as quickly as possible so
we're we're seeing fairly consistent
numbers here as well representative
Daniels for a question yeah thank you on
an average how long does it take to
close a
case it certainly dependent if it's an
inhome or outof home case um so
typically about a year or less is is
would be a potential Target for an
inhome uh case where the family remains
together um but again there's attorneys
involved um for Juvenile Justice
representing the youth there's a there's
the court oversight process ultimately
orders the closure of a case once it's
open so it's dependent on a number of
factors but a year could be a nice
Target thank
you representative Nano for a question
yes thank you very much um a quick
question on of the cases you close how
many do you have to
reopen I don't have that data with me is
I mean minimal or is it uh you know a
handful or you
know I think it's I think it's fairly
it's it's less than the number that come
in um at the onset I I think it's it's
fairly minimal um but I I don't have
that exact data with me but certainly
when we close a case we connect families
with their communities um with the
services that they can access
independent of dcyf um so more often
than not they're they're able to
function independently without our
agency thanks
on slide 19 is the agency um count of
Youth and outof home
care and you'll see the the pink line is
2024 um and overall we're looking at
um uh from 2021 to 2024 is the
span and so that that pink line being
2024 you're seeing a promising Trend um
and I showed this um in an earlier slide
with the with the child protection as
well in the decrease of the number of
children served out of their homes since
about March uh when we look at all the
data on slide 20 um this is our our
kinship data that I that I um
highlighted earlier and so um this is
children where they're placed in outof
home care and also count of children is
there on the access um so what's really
exciting here is that gold kinship um
care line and the pink is the foster
care trend line and so you're you're
really starting to see a division um
since last fall between numbers of
children served in kinship care um as
opposed to foster care um and so we're
we're really excited to see the the the
disparity growing there we we certainly
want more kids served in kinship care um
and then the blue trend line is showing
the resident IAL treatment um line which
is fairly
stable on slide 21 uh we're moving into
our syc budget our sunun use Services
budget um this is on page
864 um on the governor's budget and
accounting unit 6643
so the new you Services Center is our is
our secure uh treatment facility for for
for youth in New Hampshire um we are
certainly seeing a decrease in our
census and I have um other slides for
that coming up in a moment um and we're
building our new facility um which
should be opened in Hamstead um by late
summer early fall of 2026 um so that
process is in place um the number of
kids serving there is certainly declined
over time we're we're seeing typical
range of about 12 to 18 youth at any
given time um we ensure that we have an
appropriate Staffing pattern that allows
for the safety of Youth and staff uh we
tend to um during awake hours on on
first shift we have 14 uh youth
counselors um second shift we have
15 and um overnights we have 10 and on
weekends we ensure the staff first and
second shift the awake shifts at 15
youth
counselors um we know that we'll always
need the capacity to um spread youth um
to various units um for for many reasons
uh we could have a youth needing a a
period of Crisis stabilization uh we
certainly have new admissions coming in
um we could have a medical need to to
need to have youth be separated so we
need to make sure despite having perhaps
12 to 18 youth that we have the staff
available to spread um across the the
various units as needed um we sometimes
have court orders to keep youth um
separated they could be um you know um
they could have the same charges uh they
could have been brought in for similar
charges or the same charges in the same
crime and so we need that capacity to be
able to spread youth um ac across the
facility as
needed representative Nano for a
question followed by representative
Stringham yes thank you madam chair uh
on uh page h64 uh budget Lines 102 103
looks like a a fairly Hefty increase
that another this this another case of
money
moving from someplace else or expenses
moving from someplace else sure so one
of the one of the things that we've had
to rely on is contracted agency staff
and so you can see in the first state
fiscal year
2024 what the actual expense is there um
we've tried to account for that within
the class 103 line this year so that we
can recognize those costs um there were
other increases as well just just while
we're on the topic I I can go through a
couple of those just so that they make a
little bit more sense um another uh
fairly significant change is if you look
at instate travel
um you'll see in state fiscal year 24 it
was
126,000 um and in the budget it was
$500 so so so we budgeted $500 but we
spent $67,000 sorry where am I looking
uh so so I'm looking I'm looking at the
old budget right now for the $500 but
you would be looking at the instate
travel line in class 70 so what what
happened was there was a change within
the collective bargaining agreement
where if individuals are traveling um to
cover an overtime shift that we pay
portal to portal miles for those
individuals working at the Su use
Services Center I believe it was also in
state fiscal year 24 where we had to um
where where this was extended to other
employees from the Department that were
coming to cover shifts where we didn't
have sufficient Staffing and and let
Marie talk about sort of the progress on
the Staffing
levels sure and you'll recall that was
one of the highlights was the the
decrease in vacancies for the youth
counselor position um so we've got 46
full-time youth counselors um in total
um I can tell you uh just a few years
back we had seven of those filled um
remember trying to contemplate how we're
going to staff the facility with seven
people um and so now our our our vacancy
um is down we have six vacant positions
right now at syc um and so we've made
significant significant progress but
certainly we were required to uh pay
overtime for other people in the in the
department um in dcyf to come fill
shifts at syc and the collective
bargaining agreement um called for pay
for them for their travel um and of
course their overtime um was significant
as well so we've we've made significant
progress in that area so just a a quick
followup so line line 103
um what EXA you know just helped me
understand operation Services covers
what and then there's a Frey you know
again a significant jump up in the in
the um expenses double I guess
uh sure so the the Staffing contract was
budgeted at 1.3
million uh tutoring was approximately uh
300,000
and I don't believe that was budgeted
there
before and I can I can get additional
details on the other contracts are are
included in that line I don't recall
them off the top of my head just looks
like a pretty significant jump up
yep representative Stringham followed by
representative walner for
questions uh yeah thanks we're we're
still looking at a an in um 103 a
population of about average of about 12
right yes 12 to 18 with the goal of 12
and and are you anticipating a asking
for additional money in
2025 uh or is the 12.7 million likely
going to be adequate to get us to June
30th to start with um we're projecting
somewhere in the vicinity of $15 million
of expenses in the current
banum in the second year of the banum or
in in in in state FIS year 25 thank you
and
um I I'm you know just speaking broadly
this
is um support services for 12 children
that's enough for 500 children who are
uh just to pay for the school system
including a quarter of that being
special needs support so um it it is um
a tremendous um uh investment that that
we're making in these kids and I am
concerned with the uh the rate of growth
uh in this uh in these numbers and I'm
just wondering if you if are there any
other um uh ideas or um things you have
in mind um uh to bring these numbers
down or to bring down the uh contract or
overtime Services numbers down more than
uh than you have so
farh so we are implementing a trauma
informed model called Target um that
will roll out um the all our clinicians
are all trained our millu staff will
also be trained so that we're hoping to
um have youth uh and staff focus on the
trauma reactive symptoms and behaviors
that we're seeing of these youth um so
that is one idea that we hope will um
bring some stability and will also help
with um recidivism once kids launch from
the from the facility but I did talk
already about that multi- disciplinary
group that's coming together to think
about alternatives to syc more
specifically with the detained youth um
but I do have to tell you that the youth
that are coming to syc are coming um
often with very very violent behaviors
um assaultive behaviors um harming
others um other other youth their family
members um and so you know this is the
deepest deepest end of our system um and
so while we hope that the system of care
and all of the um outside of the agency
work might help to catch some of these
families uh we recognize that we will
have a need for a right siiz center we
know it's not 144 beds as it is now um
so we're we're again looking at that 12
um and sometimes we're up to 18 with
with some ability to divert we are
diverting lots of kids with our
diversion program and our JJ assessment
from stepping into that uh even
tiptoeing into the deeper part of our
system right once kids get into the
system sometimes behaviors exacerbate
and then they keep going deeper and
deeper so uh we've been able to stop
there but we do recognize that the youth
coming to the center's attention
currently um are coming with some pretty
significant behavioral
challenges thank you if if we could jump
to um uh 31 which which deals with this
new new uh use Center um it talks about
uh it's it's labeled H hb2 budget area
for consideration uh one thing was uh uh
this
legislature um uh authorized purchase of
a body scanner is that something that
happened or did not happen and any
comment on the on the 1 million um
budget cut that's also listed in
there so the body scanner has been
purchased so we do have it on site at
the facility so what we're currently
working through um is ensuring we have
the right policies and operating
procedures for parental consent youth
consent um how males females might
differ um regarding their ability to go
through a scanning system what we would
do if if if kids do not consent if
parents do not consent so we're in the
process of creating a policy but we do
have the scanner on site but sounds like
it's not being used yet it's not being
used yet thank
you representative
walner thank you in previous budgets we
always had in theu new Youth Services
Center we always had a lot of um
positions for
Education where how are we doing the
education now for these
kids the education is currently a
contract um I think that is class line
74 currently in accounting unit
6643 um and we do have a a contractor
providing a tutoring model to our youth
it's a it's a program that connects with
the child's School District so the the
child use to receive the educational um
Services of their individual School uh
District through a tutoring model at the
facility and and and and just to clarify
currently it's in class 74 it's being
moved to to the class 103 and that's
$300,000 annually oh okay thank you I
wondered about that so when this is sort
of looking out into the future but when
we move to the new
facility do what do you think think the
budget will look like I mean are you
anticipating that the budget will be
lower higher about the
same Nathan may want to clarify some of
my responses but we know and we
anticipate that there is going to be
some capacity for shared services um on
the Hamstead campus with Hamstead
hospital um as we all know there's been
a new contract and Dartmouth is
currently overseeing um the Hamstead
Hospital part of the of the campus and
so we are needing to work through what
those shared services will be we have
some ideas we need to regroup with the
new leadership at Hamstead hospital so
we anticipate being able to see some
cost savings but we have not been able
to identify what those are yet until we
can work that out with with the new
contractor do you anticipate any um
Staffing reductions that that it would
cost less in the new facility
I think that that's possible it would
not be youth counselor so youth
counselor staff would need to be
consistent um because we would not be
sharing right there there separate
facilities on a shared campus so we
would not be sharing our youth counselor
staff but perhaps kitchen staff or
maintenance staff um there's also the
contemplation that perhaps um for
example a new um you know a larger
kitchen or a larger laundry area is
needed so we might need more staff
because of that because we're combining
efforts so we're it's possible that we
could see some staffing shifts and and
it's just unknown
yet and and and just just to add a
little bit of background um so the the
department um had brought forward an
item to GNC to lease Hamstead Hospital
Residential Treatment Facility to
Dartmouth and there were there were four
separate agreement types within that
sort of larger package and and one of
those was a was a transition Services
agreement where basically the state
would continue continue to provide um or
provide for the contracted services that
the state was receiving and then
Dartmouth reimburses us for those costs
plus a small admin cost so we're we're
still working out for I just want to
provide this for context we're still
working with Dartmouth and they're still
making their long-term strategic
decisions on which of those contracts
they're going to keep what they're going
to absorb whether they're going to go
out to Bid And so they're working on
that transition component which is why
we don't yet have an answer for what the
shared services will look like until
they kind of make their own operational
decisions so that we can evaluate what
can be shared at that point in time okay
and one more question I have is around
medical payments to Providers do we have
nurses on staff 24 hours a day yes we do
so we have a nurse for every shift we do
have nursing on staff and so these these
payments are to providers
um that you have to take the children to
the doctor or correct it could be Labs
um clinical Labs drawn needed um maybe
x-rays if an x-ray needed to happen for
a youth for some reason but yes so it
would be those kinds of offsite things
we also have a contract um for a
hygienist and a dentist who come on site
to be able to provide that kind of care
right in the facility so that's also
included here okay and how many nurses
do we have on
staff I don't I don't know that number
exactly I can get that for you all right
thank
you representative tersi followed by
representative Nano thank you I um when
we talk about this group of children
with such high extreme needs um it
brought to mind the conversation around
out of state placements is that going to
come or is that embedded in this group
of children in the budget that's not the
right way to communicate that
but so our res presidential treatment as
we discuss in field services includes
the instate and out of state okay so we
already went past that all right but I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
have I guess I sort of missed my
opportunity to look at the numbers um
just quickly how many children do you
have out of state right now we have
about um I would say close to 60
children out of state um 6 z um but 50
of those would be in the New England
area um with about eight um out of of
what we call out of region so out of New
England okay and
um your site visits and um check-ins has
that changed at all or um budget wise
did you account for any of those changes
you might have
needed yes so um Senate Bill 417 um
provided significant changes um to the
the work that DCF does with our our
monthly visits and our um preference for
how we place children ensuring the least
restrictive um setting possible first um
so we do have prioritized need um okay
I'm going to pass that to Nathan to talk
about for 417 sure so we we we had a
couple of prioritized needs um SP 417
created um a total of 10 positions eight
cpsws and two jpos to address those
needs as well as travel dollars um we do
have some of the travel money that was
added during the governor's phase um the
positions were not um explicitly funded
wi within within the accounting units
though at this at this stage of the
process thank
you I thank you madam chair this is a
kind of a general question and you know
partly a demographics uh type question
what impact if any and uh what on on
your on the clientele uh is related to
um Refugee families or immigrant
families is that part in parcel of and
you know have you seen any impact of
that so we don't have data specific to
the refugee population but certainly We
Serve All Families that come to our
attention um I know we've gotten some
questions recently with some of the uh
Federal changes whether we're seeing any
kind of increase um in in that
population of family and we're we're not
we're not seeing any any new information
or new families coming to our attention
at this time as a result of any federal
changes okay thank you representative
priest for a
question yes uh M chairman um thank you
for taking my question um the settlement
that is going on now with the children
that have been housed in the senuna
youth service is there a line item of
potential settlement fees or how how are
you handling it so that that's handled
by the Department of Justice I I I
believe in in Prior legislative session
a trust fund was established I think at
the time $100 million was put into there
and and that's administered um Again by
by the Department of Justice DHHS is not
involved in the distribution of those
funds nor do we oversee
them okay thank you
one thing I wanted to say additionally
for um regarding the children place out
of out of state and specifically in the
New England uh region is that we often U
find that some of the bordering um towns
um actually have programs that are in
closer proximity to the family homes
than a northern uh program say for a
keen or a Nashua family so I just did
want to make that distinction and that's
why we monitor closely um New England
versus outof region placements um and
representative wner to answer your
question um to the number of nurses at
the syc there's seven
nurses thank
you representative priest for a question
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for taking my question again um on the
total number of positions um are these
employees that are being moved to I mean
it's an increase of 10 new positions on
page uh
um down toward the end so so th those
are the 10 positions I referred to
earlier they were established but when
we look globally at at the funding I I
believe those are not funded
sufficiently so that's the the s417
positions that were created that's the
eight cpsws and two
jpos sorry uh child protective service
workers okay spell that out thank
you I'm moving to slide 22 and in slide
22 shows um the trend line and this is
over a significant period of time since
2020 to 2024 to just show um the
significant decrease in the census at
syc over time um you know from from this
144 bed facility down towards um 12 18
that we see um
currently I'm moving to slide 23 and
this is the office of the director this
is um back to the beginning of of the of
the um Governor's Budget on page
848 and in in this budget um we're
seeing the director and deputy director
our constituent relations program which
is our forward facing our public Bing um
team of employees um who can manage
questions go out um and um provide
information on uh mandatory reporting to
groups of people so this is our our
public facing um team of two employees
we have our field administrators here um
and we have two employees um who focus
on the secondary trauma and the safety
of our of our staff um which really has
been a boost to our attention um you'll
see here uh 35 employees and some are
moved to other accounting units um so
that's where you might see a decrease in
the
Personnel thank you and that was the
accounting unit referred to
earlier uh
2956 thank thank you sorry about that
thank
you and I'm moving to slide 24 um which
is our Bureau of community family and
program support um this is on page
853 in the governor's budget and it's
accounting unit
2296 and so in this particular
accounting unit um we have um this is
100% Federal funding we have our um lak
which is our licensed alcohol and drug
abuse counselor um contract uh to work
with uh Ames and youth uh affected with
sub by substances and we also have our
community Navigator contract that I
referenced at Central intake to um
support families and people concerned
about families uh with with um pointing
them in the right direction outside of
the agency when
possible
um in accounting unit 2297 which is on
page
854 just just a very quick just a very
quick question on um the contracts for
uh program services for fiscal year 2025
are we running pretty much uh according
to that number or above or
below so so there's two contracts there
the the ladak contract and the community
Navigator contract um I I I would have
to go back to the invoicing detail and
statement of Appropriations to
understand where we're at these these
are 100%
um federal funds it's a Child Abuse
Prevention and treatment act so so
they're designated for specific purposes
and specific uses but but I'd have to go
back and and see where we're at today
and and and recognizing that I'm I'm
pretty certain these are cost
reimbursement and we often will see
delays in the invoicing that we receive
in excess of a month or two months or 3
months so um a point in time today may
not show you the full picture of what
the state fiscal year expenditure need
represents so the state lays out the
money and then later gets reimbursed for
it uh no so so the opposite so um by
default many of our contracts are are
cost reimbursement in the sense that the
um provider the vendor the contractor
they incur a cost and they submitted
invoice with detailed uh expenses and
supporting documentation we review it
and then once we make a determination
that the services were provided and and
or allowable then we go ahead and make
the payment okay so just a
misunderstanding of which way the
reimbursement was working yes we we do
not assume the risk okay thank
you moving to accounting unit 2297 which
is on page 854 of the governor's budget
again this these are 100% federal funds
um these are our funds for um some of
our adolesc
programs are chaffy dollars which are
used uh for Youth and Care age 14 to 21
and up to age 23 if they're in after
care voluntarily to provide things like
housing food car repairs car insurance
so ancillary services to support
adolescents um who are launching to
adulthood also our um ETV funds um
Education and Training voucher funds for
youth 18 to 26 uh who are attending
college or Career
Training moving to accounting unit 2959
on page
851 um this is funding for our domestic
violence programs um and uh the funding
that uh we're paying out for this is is
for the Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence um we also receive um
family uh violence prevention
Specialists so folks from the Coalition
who are Co located in our district
offices um alongside our case workers uh
for support to families uh requiring
those services and consultation for our
staff uh moving to accounting unit 2961
which is on page
852 um and this is our foster care
health program uh which are the nursing
staff the nurses available um in our
district offices again collocated um our
staff working alongside our case workers
regarding um the complex medical needs
of children that we serve um also
monitoring psychotropic medications um
provided by outside providers as a
secondary set of oversight um of of
those kinds of medications to ensure
that we're uh supportive of the
interventions being provided
and I'll I'll move to slide
25 uh which is a continuation of that
same Bureau of community family and
program supports um moving to accounting
unit 2969 on page 854 of the governor's
budget um this is our our cap to Dollars
which are 100% federal funds this is the
Child Abuse Prevention and treatment act
um this is the work that we do with
families um to support their
reunification to celebrate their
reunification help them um U be reminded
of of of how far they've come and and
their ability to be self-sufficient um
in the
communities um accounting unit 2973 on
page
855 this is our uh promoting safe and
stable uh families and this is our um
includes our k ship care work and our um
the work that we're doing to recruit and
retain our uh Kinship Caregivers there's
also a training component for those
caregivers um through our training
contractor in
here and moving to accounting unit 3443
on page 859
um in in this accounting unit is um
significant number um dollars for our
the services that we provide so those
Community Based Services that we were
talking about to support not only
caregivers but uh families who remain in
home um and so there's a number of
contracts here um we have our community
based voluntary Services which we talked
about our is case management uh once we
determine um we've done an investigation
there is no abuse neglect we're able to
refer families for case management um to
two uh vendors outside of the agency for
case management support so that contract
is here um we have a contract for um our
after hours um Central intake our
hotline uh we we rely on a contractor to
uh respond and answer and and process
the reports received outside of normal
business
hours we also have a strength to succeed
contract which is a contract uh built
around a model of um adults with lived
experience um in substance use and
Trauma um who we connect with families
directly to receive that coaching and
support um in order to help families
feel like they can be successful in
their work to sobriety and to um
maintaining their mental health
stability and we also have a couple of
contracts in here um uh based on
Services one in particular is our
intercept service which is a a service
um specifically designed and um is one
of our family uh first prevention and
Service Act um evidence-based Services
which is meant
to um be intensive in home supports to
maintain the family intact um and
additionally post reunification so if a
child had to have an out of Home episode
and has since been reunified The
Intercept program is a service that we
can put in place to help maintain that
family um post reunification um to be
successful representative Nano for a
question again this is probably the same
kind of a question they're all zeros in
here when I'm looking at the governor's
uh budget and this is something that has
shifted from someplace else I guess yeah
so so we we moved funds um that that we
the positions and the funding that we
were referring to earlier so there's
four separate accounts 2956 2 957 2973
and 2961 from which these dollars came
we we can do something similar and
provide a crosswalk so it's clear to the
committee sort of how the dollars moved
around yeah that that would I mean
definitely help uh sure help get my head
around the numbers absolutely thank you
representative seaworth for a question
thank you very much um could you give a
a quick summary so this is close to 5050
with the Federal Federal funding how is
the federal funding determined in this
category so the the Personnel um would
likely be cost allocated um it would be
in in in this case I'm assuming many of
these individuals be uh either
conducting a random moment study or
random Time study to uh document how
their time is spent and uh most likely
it would be fore eligible and and so
that's kind of uh I think early on we
talked a little bit about cost
allocation and it's kind of a our budget
is a Point of Departure we make
assumptions around what we would expect
so most of the time there we' expect
50/50 um depending upon the nature of
any unique contracts that might change
um which is why you wouldn't necessarily
see a 5050 split across all funds
because it would the the cost would need
to be allowable to be claimed
moving to slide
26 uh this is a new Bureau professional
and strategic development and we're
looking at accounting unit 3220 on page
857 of the governor's
budget and so in this accounting unit um
we're seeing our our employee training
contract uh sits here and so we do have
a robust training model for our new
staff um we call it Core Academy um it
trains our child protective workers our
jpos our jenal probation and pearl
officers um and our youth counselors um
it's about an 8-week program um taking
probably uh closer to three months uh
because of some time off to to do some
work back at their office shadowing
other employees um it's also training
for for uh it provides ongoing training
beyond the core training it also
provides um training for our Residential
Treatment providers and our caregivers
so it it provides um all all of our
training
needs
um a very quick question could you could
you kind of roughly characterize uh what
kinds of training absolutely yes so um
for our child protective service workers
um the investigative training there are
certain tracks there's some training
that are you um Carry forward to all of
our client facing position and then
there's certain tracks so for our
investigators there would be um
trainings around
interviewing um engaging with families
and making sure that we have the ability
to sit and partner with families and
listen to them and understand their
needs um that would be a training that
would be unique across all of them uh
for our youth counselors um they'd
receive um special training on being in
the milu on their units um how to
deescalate um a youth whose um you know
symptoms may be um exacerbated and and
may be having some challenging behaviors
uh for our family service our ongoing
case workers in child protection they
would have specific training around case
planning with children um all of the
areas have training unique to the legal
aspects of their jobs what to expect in
court um how they might write particular
reports or or information so we'll have
different uh trainers come in with the
specialty in those particular areas in
order to enhance our staff um initial
education thank you for that thank
you representative priest for a question
thank you Madame chairman and thank you
for taking my question again as a
clarification uh this new align item
3220 is supposed to take care of all the
training needs for this division is that
correct there was um a reference to the
a training contract in a prior um in the
kinship as well but yes the bulk of our
our training happens here okay good
thank
you uh we also have some contracts in
this accounting unit um we have a a
contract for a program that we call risk
and safety consultation um which is
meant to um be a quality assurance
control over our most intensive
investigations um so those that require
um the most care the most investigative
processes to ensure that we have a group
of Staff um also reviewing we it's a
very small team but we have a small team
reviewing alongside um our district
offices to ensure that nothing safety
related is overlooked so it's a coaching
mod model and a quality improvement
model so you'll see that contract um
sits in here um we also do have
um our can's contract sits here as well
which is our Child and Adolescent needs
and strengths tool that our Juvenile
Justice assessment team is using um to
assess uh the needs and and strengths of
Youth to be able to then ensure we can
meet those needs we're going to be
carrying that over to a child protective
staff as well so those that those
contracts sit
here in addition to training um in in
this unit we um as I mentioned we have
the risk and safety consultation that
those coaches uh for our investigators
we also have um implementation science
staff who are focused on um delivering
special projects our strategic
priorities for example monitoring uh
reviewing the data that comes out of
that making sure that we're staying on
track so that is sits within this
Bureau moving to slide 27 on page 8
58 this is accounting unit 3221 this is
our Bureau of evaluation analytics and
Reporting this is a small team um that
comprises the dcyf data analytics um
Team our quality assurance and
Improvement team and our federal
reporting so in class line
um 26 I I I wanted to point out um this
this is our um a data analytics um
service that um scours the dcyf data
each day so every single morning we can
come in and be able to re review a
dashboard our case workers can look at
things uh regarding their casework uh
which clients might need to be seen um
any number of data points regarding
permanency and out of home care and
face-to-face contact UM with with
children and families so it provides um
a a dashboard of avail able um
information that helps not only field
workers but all levels of the agency
monitor practice and and see where we
need to pay
attention moving to slide 28 on page
860 this is a new accounting unit um so
many of these staff were originally in
that if you remember there were 35 Staff
in the director's office um previously
um so this is a a new accounting unit
which is comprised of our general
Council um which includes our policy
inform form development and our child
abuse and neglect central registry as
well as our business Information Systems
um group of Staff which um over SI case
management system our our Legacy system
that we currently have as well as will
um focus on the the build um and roll
out of our new electronic case
management system and provide overall it
support this is and I'm sorry I think I
failed to mention this is accounting
unit 3444 on page
860 and there's a few contracts um
overseen here um in the um Information
Systems group um in particular our syc
case management system bizstream um is
this contract sits here um as does a
couple other contracts uh we're
developing a contract for video storage
and viewing um so kids who have
experienced um um significant uh neglect
and abuse often um receive their initial
um child interview at a Child Advocacy
Center uh when a crime could have been
committed um where there's forensically
uh trained interviewers and law
enforcement um perhaps county attorney's
office um dcyf staff can all uh
participate in the child interview um at
the same time to minimize Reliance on um
or uh minimize dup duplicative
interviews of of a child victim and so
those interviews are videotaped and and
we're needing to ensure that we have uh
storage that we have um the software
available to view um those interviews
that are coming to us through the job
advocacy centers um and so we have a
contract here to ensure that that we
don't lose that important um evidence as
we're trying to protect children um so
those are a couple of the contracts um
in this accounting
unit moving to slide
29 um we did talk um a bit about this
already this is um the cable uh 463 and
uh 4117 is the oversight of Residential
Treatment um which impacts enhanced
oversight um by our child protective
service workers um and the courts and um
outlines the order of preference of how
children's uh placement is
contemplated um Senate Bill
463 um is a new bill that would um
require that children in residential
treatment um will have court appointed
Council um that will represent their
expressed interest um again for any
child in residential treatment and that
could be expanded to any other child
interested in in in that representation
and and our field staff will be
informing the children of their right
notifying Court um and and that will
have a phased in approach
um but that was um defrayed by in the
governor's budget representative walner
for a
question you
you so Senate Bill 463 spent a lot of
time in this committee last
year
and could you remind
me
what on these lines the
um I I guess you have it on two pages
right it's both
on page 29 and then again on page 30
representative wner it it looks like
there was a printing er error um I I
would dis it looks like page 29 was from
an earlier version as we were updating
it so I I would go ahead and strike out
on your document page 29 as the accurate
numbers are located on page 30 apologize
for that okay because I was trying to
figure out are these two different two
different things but okay um so I guess
my question
is what exactly does the department need
funding to do and um because this is not
the attorneys this is not the children's
the lawyers for the
children so our fiscal note contemplated
uh an additional 14 cpsws so so what we
know and appreciate and and we believe
that kids Express rights um deserve to
be um brought to the attention of the
court and all the parties we also know
that there'll be additional um needs on
the on the on on the behalf of our of
our child protective uh case workers um
having meetings with kids to inform them
of their rights filling out forms for
kids that are going to
um for all of the kids in residential
treatment plus other kids um who uh
request um an attorney we know that um
because this is for residential
treatment um to contemplate that most
youth will have the expressed wish to
remain in residential treatment is
unlikely um we anticipate there'll be um
motions um hearings um additional work
being done with with those attorneys to
make sure that we are able to meet those
youth
needs so can you I guess I I have a hard
time understanding what
14 new positions would do I mean you're
you're informing the children they're
already they're already have I assume
they already have a social worker yes
they already have a social worker how
much time would this add if say they
were no CPA no for no new 14 how much
time would this add do you think to the
average social workers work with their
clients I think it it's it's it will be
the court hearings and and the motions
and working with the attorneys that
would be um most of the time um yes
there'd be forms and and discussions
that need to be held but we anticipate
the majority of the time will be spent
um in in
court or in working with those attorneys
around again the expressed wishes of
those of those youth
impacted so the 14 amounts to about one
new cpsw per area with a couple of our
larger offices receiving two but so it
would be one additional cpsw to spread
the casework respon
responsibility so presently since the
children don't get a
lawyer that work doesn't get
done or are the cpsws having
to do some of that work in
court well they currently all of the
children receive a guardian at lium
which could be a casa or an attorney
guard Guardian lium um and and those
people are um looking into the best
interest of the children and might not
align with the child's
interest so this with with the council
that would be coming on board it's the
express interest so what the child is
saying they want regardless of what
someone else thinks is their best
interest so we'll have a guardian of
lium per for each child and also um a
cour a court appointed attorney um
talking about what the child wishes so
we anticipate with the residential
treatment that there there will be
additional um many additional steps to
be taken uh with a child protective
worker with that attorney with perhaps
court with motions with filings and
discuss discussion around what else we
could do to meet that child's needs um
that would be new than than is currently
happening
today so presently though the social
worker must be meeting with the casus
and the guardian at Liams right yes so
they're already involved in doing some
of that kind of oversight making sure
that everyone's I guess doing what
they're supposed to be doing that's
correct that falls to the social worker
at this time yes it does okay I guess I
still have a really hard time
understanding how having the child have
their own
lawyer is going
to cause it to be more work for the
social worker but I'll take your word
for it that at least the department
thinks it it would increase the uh the
need
um so this was all it was also in the
legislation it was going to be phased in
so it would be
just a few children and then added I
think it was by age that's correct that
they were going to be phased in and even
at at even with the phase in you still
feel like you still need 14 additional
workers yes we we do believe best
interest and express interest are going
to be two very different things and so
we anticipate needing needing another
staff in each office uh due to the
additional work that will be on each of
our
staff thank you representative Stringham
for a question yeah I'm sure we have a
few weeks to go over it but it seemed to
me that I U my memory of of the
discussion we had on this that they
thought there was at least equal
offsetting um expenses in another
category by by adding the staff and I
don't know if you can speak to that or
whether we'll just wait and uh see if my
memory is accurate and uh in in the
process of working on the budget over
the next few weeks I don't think I can
speaked to that I'm
sorry and and and just for General uh
awareness um s SP 463 it was passed
during the legislative session of 2024
but it had a July 1 of 2025 start date
so starting in the next B anym and so
there's um there's two components to the
prioritize need one is the cpsws here
and then there's also there was a um
prioritized need relative to dcyf
attorneys five dcyf attorneys but those
attorneys are actually budgeted in legal
and Regulatory Affair so when Melissa sa
SE was here maybe almost two weeks ago
now um that that that would impact her
budget area and and those were the costs
that were recognized in the Department's
analysis that showed up in the um in the
lb's fiscal note uh on that bill but
that bill made no
appropriation and currently in the draft
hb2 um that uh that particular effective
date has been delayed until the start of
the subsequent by the next by
anym moving to slide
32 can can we I have questions on slide
30 sorry oh sure just looking down the
prioritized needs there on slide 30 um
can you just maybe we touched on this
and I apologize that $9 million in 27
for Medicaid loss of funding for
residential what is that sure so
we we included in our original agency
budget request an $18 million general
fund request for the loss of the
Medicaid dollars and that goes back to
the discussion relative to the the qrtp
IMD where we're no longer um going to be
able to claim those Medicaid funds
that's been partially funded in in the
in the governor's recommended budget um
so so the $9 million is the anticipated
um remaining amount that that that we
projected when we prepared our budget
request representative Stringham for a
question can you comment on the
residential rate increase and Foster
Care rate increases what percentage that
represents um
I I can I can go back and get you what
percentage that may represent I think
what's important to understand is that
it doesn't mean a 4% increase for
everybody um that number was based on an
analysis where we collected uh cost
report data from the residential
treatment providers and we looked at
what the costs were to deliver the
services and and so that number
represents that level of analysis and so
there would be variations between each
of those residential providers um so
it's not a it's not necessarily a fixed
rate um do you know the foster care
rate we can provide that to okay um for
the Foster Care uh rate increases and
and again we we realize there's costs
here but these both residential and
Foster Care are essential services to
our service array um to ensure that kids
receive the treatment kids we have
places for kids to go who require out of
home care because their their their home
is dangerous right so that's when we
remove when we determine that a child is
not safe in their home so we we need
these available options um to be able to
serve New Hampshire's children um in
regard to the foster care rate increases
um there is a calculation um regarding
cost of living uh cost to raise a child
so there there is a a method that we um
calculated in order to um consider what
kind of foster care raises should happen
um on an annual basis um to to ensure
that people can care for for the
children that placed in their home and
so I do have the daily foster care rates
um in the anticipated rate per day um
and just in general um for State fiscal
year 2025 um they range from about $34 a
day um up to about $50 a day depending
on the the age um of the child and then
we also have other specialized kinds of
rates um emergency or crisis um care
that a family may provide to us so we
can provide you these rates so that you
can see the the rate increases over time
um based on the daily rate that we
established I follow up um um the
residential rate increase which is a
cost based
reimbursement so um if if if we don't
provide this amount the we would have to
uh necessarily reduce the number of of
uh residential units that we have
available to meet the budget so what
what it would mean is
um pot potentially a couple of different
things one is we hold the daily
reimbursement rate steady with with no
change um so for the current state
fiscal year there were no increases
because there there was no money
budgeted for that purpose if the
prioritized needs request is not
approved then um we wouldn't have money
to provide rate increases for 26 or
27 and similarly for foster care the the
prioritize need would cover the
anticipated rate increases that we um
have calculated for foster
care representative walner for question
did I understand you to just say there
was no rate increase for Foster care or
Residential Treatment Residential Care
in this bium the one no there there was
so the the the first year for
residential there there was a rate
increase but in the second year of the
bayum we didn't have funds sufficient to
provide that rate increase in the second
year so they got one rate increase
during the the bium yes for for
residential yes and what about foster
care did they have a rate increase
yes I believe they did one rate rate
increase
okay and and to your question U
representative Stringham regarding
residential treatment so certainly we we
hear from providers um the challenges
that they have to meet their budget um
and so it it does concern us that not
being able to provide the funding that
they need to run their program could
minimize the the number of programs or
beds that we have would could cause us
to need uh additional beds out of out of
state um out of state programs are
certainly more costly we're sending
staff out to visit these programs on a
monthly basis to meet uh with kids in in
in the program areas um who serve them
so you know we certainly hope that we
can at a minimum keep the programs that
we have in
state representative n valeno for a
question n
I uh this is just kind of a curiosity
question we send kids to other states
and other states have their own programs
for handling this what what interaction
or is there any potential for you know
instead of doing the travel there um
cooperating with other states
reimbursing them and and everybody saves
money by having it handled you know in
the location where the where the child
is actually located
there is actually a process for that
called the interstate compact for the
placement of children and it allows for
that reciprocity and that capacity for
other states to monitor the children in
their state um with the passage of
Senate Bill 417 uh we are now
legislatively required to go out the the
person that knows the child to do to do
those visits directly so that is a
direct impact of that legislation so we
will always be traveling to meet with
the children in our Care on a monthly
basis so so if I understand we're not
really taking full advantage of the
compact as it relates to to Residential
Treatment that's correct okay thank
you representative tki I was just for
the representative um s SP 417 was um
came out of an unfortunate situation of
New Hampshire children that were in an
out of-state placement that was unsafe
to them and inhumane and and um so the
legislation was filed to protect the
children and make sure that they have
more regular um visits from um people
here in the granite state who were
looking out for their
Care thank you that's kind of
educational for me because I'm new to
the
uh um moving to slide 32 which is
essentially the the the last detailed
slide that I have here um this is simply
a depiction of some of the service
delivery impacts and and how that
affects our case workers um at DCF and
so ultimately case workers are
responsible for for the needs of the the
children and families on their case load
and so when we have um fiscal impacts
that that impact things like foster care
and foster parents and and residential
rates and transportation um cuts or
inability to provide the rate that um
that meets the the provider needs that
does fall on on the casew worker um in a
recent example our transportation
provider needed to to cut back some of
the work that they did so what that
means is our case workers are getting up
before work they're traveling to pick up
children um drive them to school um
drive them to family time and visits um
if we have foster parents and um that
that we can't retain or they're impacted
by finances it means fewer foster homes
it means our staff traveling to visit
children further and further away
whether that's in residential um or
foster care um so really I I just wanted
to make the connection between sometimes
just not having some of
this it doesn't mean it's just simply
not available it means it has to get
picked up somewhere and the majority of
these things get picked up by our case
workers um who are extremely dedicated
passionate about the work that they do
um again we're available 24 hours a day
7 days a week uh meeting the needs of
our our most vulnerable population um
and so I just I wanted to be able to
highlight that here uh to just um show
how that does impact the work we do and
ultimately when when our case workers
are doing some more of those ancillary
um aspects of the work they're they're
ultimately spending less time uh doing
their case work uh with with Children
and
Families representative Daniels for
question thank you can visitations be
done virtually
so we do some off um so in addition to
our monthly face-to-face contact which
which must happen we do um in between we
can do some kinds of virtual contact uh
phone contact or video conference
certainly support families um who can't
make um a meeting to be able to do so
remotely but we are required um inperson
face-to-face contact
monthly representative Stringham for a
question I'm and thank you for for this
slide and of course all the all the work
that uh you and your staff do uh for the
children in our state and and I had
written down this question to ask you
what you thought uh the state of mind
and of the case workers are are they
feeling overburdened are they on the
brink of being burned out or are they uh
uh you know kind of in a happier place
how would you overall um
characterize uh where we we are in here
and uh if you have any
recommendations um you know outside of
what's in the budget already it'd be
interested as well yeah thank you for
that question
um I child welfare work Child Protection
Juvenile Justice is is challenging it's
tough the secondary trauma is intense um
the things that they see experience read
talk to kids about um it's very very
difficult and challenging um
yesterday I was in a a meeting with our
our management team so group of our
senior supervisors administrators and I
was hearing them talk to me as I'm
talking about our priorities about how
overwhelmed their staff are um all good
things Senate Bill 417 is very
complicated requires a lot of their time
uh we've had countless new forms and
processes and standard operating
procedures you know as a result of
something that seems like really good
legislation and and we do want to
protect kids we want to be there for
kids but each and every one thing that
happens has a immense ripple effect on
our staff so our our staff our staff are
overwhelmed um we try to support the
best we can um we we have that safety
culture team that I mentioned in the
director's office budget trying to
support their secondary trauma needs um
what we know is any bit of negative
media attention whether it's YDC
litigation whether it's other litigation
whether it's a story from 10 years ago
um what what that does and the impact
that that has on our staff um is pretty
intense um it erodes Family Trust it
erodes the way that people communicate
with us it erodes the way Community
Partners communicate with us um our
staff get threatened all of the time um
we were at a pretty a pretty um High we
we have documented 50 threats uh to our
staff in calendar year 2024 so we track
that we try to support them we offer
them um help um but it's it it is a very
challenging job and uh while we've made
a lot of progress on our retention um
that just speaks to the commitment of
our team um and their ability to to
stick with it and to want to do better
for kids and families and so we remain
fully committed we remain wanting to
always do better we have a lot of work
to do we acknowledge that um it's nice
to also acknowledge some of the good
work that we do for our staff to feel
like people know that the commitment
that they have the good work that they
do the 247 operation that we maintain um
so overall I appreciate your your
question it's it's tough at es and flows
depending um on the temperature in in
the community um and on uh the new
practices that that roll out and and
come to fruition but um we remain a
committed group of about 750
people representative Nano for question
yeah first of all I'd like to uh uh
commend you for the uh presentation that
you given today very uh informative very
detailed thank you U you know subject to
getting some of the simplification on
where the money was moving around but
I'm wondering if uh you know you made
mention of the fact that you've got a a
whole array of complex rules regulations
and everything is there anything that U
you know U you might do to recommend the
legislature places where we could um uh
reduce the without harming without
harming any of the uh quality of the
services that you could you from your
side of it could say say some of these
rules these regulations and
administrative aspects of this could be
streamlined or simplified that would at
one and the same time uh improve the
operations quality and maybe even
contribute to uh the
morale I can give some more thought to
that you know I think we appreciate the
flexibility even in some of our
contracts um it it it it would be nice
to know that if we do really significant
active contract management so knowing
that we could have the ability to say
you know this contract isn't living up
maybe to the the benefits that we would
have hoped for for families so be able
to Pivot that money and and apply it in
a way that is um for the services that
work right that flexibility is is
greatly appreciated I think anything
that we can also do around prevention
so serving families outside of the
DCF agency is is where and it's not to
divert the the work that dcyf needs to
do I know the work that we need to do
you you probably all see the work that
we need to do but there has to be equal
attention on the outside of the system
the education system the medical
providers the folks that see families
and kids every single day that can catch
that kid that they notice in school uh
drifting off that that that they're
knowing is staying up late you know
perhaps something's going on in the home
so there's there's such an array of 211
and other services Family Resource
Centers um places that we can point
families and and and catch them before
they get to the the place of um you know
an unfortunate uh neglect or abusive
situation happening we know abuse often
happens in the context of everyday
events we know most families don't wake
up and say I'm going to abuse my child
today right there's things that happen
and and families are complex systems and
so I think as a as a community as a as a
as a group of citizens in New Hampshire
um to the extent that we can consider
how we um divert attention um to the
earlier point in our communities um and
away from our system is is really where
I I hope to see a large focus of our
work I I just make one other uh further
comment is that certainly I have a
vested interest I have 15 grandkids and
have five uh adult children that are
that are married so I have some
familiarity with the issues and the uh
and the challenges uh that are presented
so I you know you're doing great work
and uh hopefully we can uh help you do
it in a more efficient cost effective
and and uh timely manner thank you
representative Daniel for a question
thank you compared to the intake numbers
there are significant numbers of
screened out things have you given any
thought as to how you might be able to
educate people so that you don't get the
the the calls that don't amount to
anything and thereby save time for the
workers that's a great question thank
you um we actually were working through
a program where we were trying to
consider how to provide the community it
was a community Response Guide um how to
provide the community alternatives to
reporting um there was mixed reaction uh
from many of our community stakeholders
being concerned that people would begin
to under report um but I think there is
an Avenue to potentially consider um how
to
have um in in this model it was going to
be almost like a decision-making tree
but less in my opinion less about should
I report to DCF if I'm thinking I should
report to DCF I should report to DCF uh
what we know because we surveyed um some
of our reporters is that um it was
something like 70% of reporters called
in a report to DCF not because they
actually suspected abuse neglect but
because they knew a family needed help
and they didn't know what else to do and
so um the the effort that we were doing
was trying to be a a a Community
Education a a response guide to say I
this family needs help let me walk
through this online tool maybe the
outcome will be a report to DCF Maybe it
will be something else it could be again
211 a a a pantry um a hotline number a
lot of a lot of people realize that
something's happening but they don't
know what to do about it to help um so
we have um our community Response Guide
was was was was not funded again it was
not um it was not appreciated by all
members of our um oversight bodies Our
communities um and so you know that that
was reduced um in the government
govern's budget and and I think that's
okay um one thing that I can point to
though is the that that is kind of a
more intense um service that we often
see some of these families go to some of
our families go to is um our children's
Behavioral Health System of care which I
believe you'll receive a presentation on
this tomorrow um through our um division
of Behavioral Health and so that is um a
way for families to get the help that
they need outside of the system could
even include include Residential
Treatment again as an episode of
treatment so we're trying to provide all
layers of capacity you know your very
basic support in your communities the
funding the department does to Family
Resource Centers um to a system of care
that exists with paid Services
Residential Treatment outside of DCF for
families that really need help and then
when you come to DCF this Bast AR Ray of
services so we're trying to catch um the
various various levels um and I think
when I think the work still to be done
with communities and and we're going to
be a partner here um to do this is is
that just that very early on uh work to
catch um again I I'm sorry to call out
Educators and medical providers but
those are the typical people that see
kids you know from from preschool you
know right up through age 18 and how to
make sure that we're communicating
enough where those other resources are
um so that families do not pick up the
phone and we don't have those screen
outs that are taking time away um you
know from from from calls that could
come in um the only thing I'll say about
screen outs though is that it it does
point to that Community Navigator
program um so I I don't want it to
appear that those families got nothing
from dcyf so we can refer them to that
program where the family and the
provider get education about what could
be available you don't need our service
but here's some other things that could
be helpful so that that next call
doesn't come
in well thank you both very much Miss
Nan Mr White Once Again a very thorough
detailed and informative presentation
and we're very appreciative so thank you
again for all the important work you do
we do recognize this is not easy and uh
we wish you all the best for another
cycle and certainly are glad you're here
representative
priest thank you madam chairman and uh
before
you before we end this uh session um
will you be providing us with actual
numbers of of people that you have
serviced instead of giving us a vague
description like we've increased or we
decreased you know whatever that's in
your
um in your briefing book um that would
be very helpful to us I'd be happy to do
that um some of the if you could also go
back uh if you have the numbers five
years so we can see that you are you are
making progress in this
area I'd be happy to do that um some of
the tables do have count of Youth um but
I it sounds like you're looking for a
bit more detail so I'll be happy yes s
I'm looking for much more detail thank
you all right thank you both thank you
so much for your time at this point I'm
going to open it up to those of the
public who wish to make
comments as a time check we are uh 2
hours and 44 minutes
in if you do come up please state your
name very clearly and who you represent
okay welcome to division
three are you are you okay with the TW
for okay yes okay with the two I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center I'm Lisa
Wolford thank you I'm the executive
director of the children's Law Center of
New Hampshire and you've heard so much
information you've got so much in front
of you um what I'm hoping that we we
would zero in on at least what I want to
zero in on is the um s SP 463 or right
to council for children in the foster
care system that was um exclude or
postponed in the draft Governor's hb2
and I just want to remind this committee
that um well first of all um this bill
passed on a Voice vote on both the
Senate side and the and the house side
and it came out of this committee um
with a unanimous recommendation ought to
pass with an
amendment and what that Amendment did
when it when it was when it passed out
of the Senate um there were um 14 cpsw
positions in the bill but this committee
did not buy that any of those positions
were
necessary and so um there was an
amendment to the Senate bill that did a
couple things um it addressed the um
what this committee I think perceived as
an
overinflated um request for additional
staff and it took out all that staff
there were other concerns that had to do
with um concerns about whether there
would be enough attorneys to represent
these children and so the other thing
that the amended version ultimately did
was establish a phase in schedule
because I think there was a concern that
if
this law became effective on July 1 that
all of a sudden there would be around
120 children would all be entitled to
council at the same time and so the
amendment actually included a phas in um
by age of child for every three months
um so these concerns were addressed this
committee met three times um on this
particular bill um and had really
lengthy discussions some of you are
probably having PTSD about it right
because you were here there was a lot of
discussion there was actually another
amendment that passed and then didn't
and you all spent a lot of time and the
reason I think you spent a lot of time
um is although you are a I understand
you are a fiscal committee or finance
committee I think that you are also
impressed with the fact that New
Hampshire is an outlier in this country
when it comes to representation for
Children and Youth who are in the foster
care system we guarantee Council for
kids in the Juvenile Justice System
chins and kids who are in the
delinquency system but we are one of
only six states in the country that
never under any circumstances provide a
right to counsel for children who are in
the foster care system who I remind you
are in the system not because of
something that they did in particular
which you know lands kids in the
Juvenile Justice System but because
their parents allegedly or maybe were
proven to have abused or neglected them
and um and so that's that made us an
outlier and this is something that the
committee seemed really committed in the
whole house and the whole Senate and our
governor thought was important at the
time so um that said remembering that
I'm in a finance committee something to
remember here is that the there there
are a couple of financial factors here
too one is that as you heard the
department has a goal to re reduce its
Reliance on residential
placement and in doing so if they're
successful and I really hope they are
that will reduce the number of children
who are entitled to counsel right
because we will be referring fewer
children for residential um Cong when I
say residential I'm only talking about
residential treatment or congregate
settings okay it will reduce the number
of children who would then be entitled
to councel under this law right because
fewer kids who are at risk fewer kids
were replaced fewer kids entitled to
attorneys the other thing is that some
of these kids who have attorneys who are
probably expressing their interest to
not be taken out of their homes and put
in an Institutional kind of setting some
of them are going to win right and even
if a few of them win that's going to
save the state hundreds of thousands
probably over a million or millions of
dollars because these places are not
cheap you know they can be a few
hundred, a year for some of them I Lisa
would probably know some of them maybe
more
so this this does two things right it
accomplishes a really important policy
matter um and provides a voice for some
of our most vulnerable kids who are
looking at really you know ter you don't
grow up like whatever normal means for a
teenager if you are in any kind of
institutional setting if you're ripped
out of your community your school your
friends right so IT addresses that but
it also has some potential cost savings
and the committee really like I said
didn't see the need for all the staff
that um the dep department has
requested
so real good thank you for that
refresher very helpful in terms of um
remembering how this went through
anything to add yes please sure the
children's Law Center provides
representation to children in chins
delinquency and abuse and neglect cases
so I um actively represent children
children who are placed in uh
institutional settings um and argue that
they be returned to family based
settings I am extremely skeptical of um
the utility uh the efficacy um and the
benefit to Children of institutional
placement and you are you are you are
right to ask for data on many different
things um but but that is one thing I
would also seek because we don't don't
have outcome data in New Hampshire on
the benefits to Children placed in these
institutions and as uh one of the
representatives mentioned placement out
of state we have found to be in fact
harmful to children and so these kids
need counsel now it is unfortunate that
the state of New Hampshire has become so
dependent on institutional placement I
think it has one of the worst records in
the country for sending children uh out
of their communities and institutional
and into institutional placement um so
there's a real human cost to this right
it it is not beneficial for children's
psychological emotional um developmental
uh development um and if we set up kids
up for failure now then there's a cost
to New Hampshire down the line because
these are the kids who will leave
institutional care uh without high
school diplomas um without job skills
and uh at higher risk to um to be
involved in the adult criminal legal
system which you all know is extremely
expensive um the the the uh
division has said Miss Newton uh said
that it would be Court related work that
would require additional uh CPS W time
it it is hard for me to see that um the
work that the cpsws do now should they
should already be doing the work of
understanding why a child should be they
should know their justification for
placing a child in institutional care
and and so that work should be done the
other thing about the number of hearings
is that
sb47 has essentially spelled out when
hearings about institutional placement
uh can occur and in fact judges are not
required to have hearings they they if a
a child's lawyer files a motion asking
uh saying to a judge that institutional
placement is uh not necessary in the
case or won't serve the child the judge
does not have to have a hearing on that
the judge can simply review the matter
so that's RSA 169
f84 uh I encourage the the the committee
to to take a a look at that so these
hearing
will coincide with regular review
hearings there may be some additional
hearings that is possible I'm not saying
that it's not but but I I I do not see
how that would require 14 additional
cpsw staff even the one per office um
that Miss Nunan talked
about um I think you know
the the other thing to think about as uh
as Karen mentioned is the cost of
Institution placement you know we send
we have a level system from level level
two uh which is um very unintensive not
restrictive uh residential placement up
to level five which is the prtf I just
pulled some dollars uh dollar statistics
from DCF contracts and uh for a level
two placement and and a that that level
two child should be served in the
community their behavior can be
addressed in the community at Spalding
um Community uh residential it's
$789 a day that's almost
$300,000 a year for a single child even
with a federal offset of $4 49% you're
looking assuming assuming that happens
that there is an almost 50% Federal
offset you're looking at
$141,000 for a single child for a year
so lawyers can do two things they can
keep children out of residential
placement as Karen um remarked and then
if a child is sent to residential
placement they can get them home sooner
or get them Ste down into less expensive
care in a family based setting
sooner thank you very much for that
information any questions for our guests
yes representative
noveno yeah if I if I hear what you're
saying I you know and and maybe rephrase
this because I stood Miss nunan's
presentation to say the focus was on
directionally reducing the out of uh you
know the institutional placement which I
think is consistent uh with what you're
saying and so uh what else uh could
could be done to you know um uh kind of
uh augment that effort that already
exists you know the everybody realizes
the costs and and and I would agree with
the sentiment that
probably uh has some detrimental aspects
uh to it for a lot of lot of different
reasons not to go into them but what uh
would you suggest that uh DCF ought to
be
doing uh to kind of uh okay help with
achieving their
objectives yes well investment in the
children's system of care and the
problem is that that this state is so
stuck so addicted to residential
placement and so committed to funding it
I mean I think um there the
DCF asked presented a contract to the
executive Council in June or July of
2024 um that sought approval of $365
million for a two-year period right and
probably some federal offset there it's
a huge price tag for around 300 50 kids
at any point in time maybe 4 to 500 a
year and so unless we take that money
now um and invest it in foster care in
ISO foster care so Therapeutic Foster
Care um invested in other community-
Based Services we support intercept for
example which is a Youth Villages
services that dcyf seeks funding again
for this year uh we support the funding
of um of CMEs uh Care Management
entities which is is uh something that
135f the children's system of care
called for several years ago um but that
money you you can't keep
funding the obscenely high price tag of
institutional
care yeah I just make the comment I mean
I'm as I said I'm a relatively new
legislature not new to a lot of the
related issues on this and I would say
that uh I think we're all on the same
page uh it's just a question of you know
how do we and and I don't know whether
you know how to take this the fact that
I'm addicted to uh making the most cost
effective uh decisions on providing the
best services and so that's what I'm
addicted to from the financial
standpoint and so the question is how
can if we're all on the same page then
all we're talking about is what's the
best means of achieving uh the goals
that satisfy the the basic remit of uh
uh what we're doing here in health and
human services and and do it in the most
cost effective way so anyhow thanks uh
thanks for your input thank you
representative tarki I was just going to
ask um when we are going to be
discussing the system of care and these
prevention um services so that we can
really dig into the topic excellent
question in fact I was just pulling out
my schedule I believe that is is
representative oh excuse me Mr
Ripple so get the Bureau of Behavioral
Health tomorrow um so it would be part
of that
conversation okay as early as
tomorrow another consideration in terms
of the financial investment that the
state is making in residential cares I
think you heard earlier that um we're
currently the state is able to collect
Federal matching funds Medicaid funds
for facility that they're called IMDB's
institutions for mental disease I hate
that name but anyway that serve more
than 16 children but that's under a a
kind of Tim limited waiver that the
state was able to obtain from CMS and
that is going to expire so um so for in
terms of like the amount that the state
is investing in residential treatment
for children who are at these larger
facilities the federal match at least
the Medicaid match is not going to be
available um and I think the department
will know exactly what the timeline is
and I think that's included in the
budget and explains some of the
difference and why the federal
reimbursement went down because that
will not be available but Medicaid does
pay for community- based medical
treatment and
therapy anything further from the
committee thank you both very much thank
thank you all
anything further from those here from
the
public all right with that then we will
start to wind down our work session
precisely 4
o'clock a reminder we're back here
tomorrow February 27th at 10: a.m. for a
budget work session on the division of
Behavioral
Health do watch the weather and drive
carefully
anything further from Members before we
close all right with that we're going to
close the work session division 3 on
February 26th thank you
all for